the OBS is started alright I got the
notification let me know addict if he
sound good and all that good stuff
alright commercial all right
hey we owe laughs welcome to the iron
Louis podcast and the Lord's a gaming
dotnet episode number 135 it is another
glorious Sunday we're back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got unto the end PS 5
leaks game of the ward discussions
amazon entering the streaming room to
discuss so we gonna get right into it
I wanna introduce the Lord whose journey
I paid extreme close attention to this
project North first caught my eye in
2017 the subtle atmospheric storytelling
of the environments combined with the
visceral combat animations of our
favorite torment look alike invoke
strong fields of limbo inside out of
this world and of course Game of Thrones
introducing one half of the dynamic
husband-and-wife duo of the two ton
studios and creative director of the
highly anticipated unto the end video
game franchise the Lord of a threes ID
at Xbox segment and by far the coolest
punch-out fan in the realm live from
California by way of Canada and making
his debut into the realm of the Lord's
my man Lord Stephen Denton of 2-ton
studios are you doing sir yeah excellent
guys thanks so much for having me on
you know appalled used everyone Sarah
wasn't isn't able to make it she's
helping a friend right now but she
passes along her or you know her her
clothes and and and what was salute
salute man you are a Lord at what you do
I know we have been in discussion for
some time to get this happening man
absolute pleasure to have you around man
we about that some fun back thanks for
coming buddy
no and of course you know we got the
Four Horsemen of gaming those original
realms the Lords of the realm at the
round table my coals with the cold lost
my brother from another mother the
difficult game Conqueror Lord of reviews
and the half of the young wolf mommy
Lord I'm struggling sleep last week I
had no sleep of course we have the most
technical gaming Lord the solo game is
for the single-player surface experience
and also the sastra Damas mr. Flom
profile Illuminati and Lord patreon of
the I'd bake mommy
Lord sovereign how you doing sir I'm
doing good good morning gentleman wide
awake you know you know old people wake
up early right I finally got invited to
the party finally I'm in the X cloud
party I'm dreaming man I have to say I
really have to say man it is super
impressive what I'm able to play on a 4d
LTE connection
yeah it really feels like they tell you
like hey man really five do when you're
on the Wi-Fi 5g obviously they're
looking forward to two
why a 5g data to be the point that
really kind of sends the message that
streaming is for real but honestly what
they're able to accomplish on 4G else is
pretty impressive it's damn impressive I
was playing I had a little bit of an
issue yesterday and katsu helped me out
with the my right analog stick wasn't
responding but I guess I just needed an
update he did that whatever Oh
controller update yes yes yeah I didn't
realize it didn't it didn't prompt me to
do it so I didn't realize what was
happening so the man I played I played a
little bit of everything crackdown 4 is
oh and like man if you got connection to
study you're getting a pretty a pretty
decent experience is what Meagan sees
the thing is I think Kareem Chaudhary
said it like he's like listen we're not
trying to sell you mystical arts here
like right there's always gonna be
latency right well you play even if
you're playing on your couch you're
gonna have latency it's a matter of
making the latency consistent across the
board so then you get accustomed to it
and then you're playing just fine like
anything else so it's not like you know
the stadia negative latency thing with
it we're saying that on Friday yeah I
think what you said I think that has
something to do with the cross they off
we'll get to you close again the
predictive technology I think is real
but it's just the way they're saying
it's it's it's like black magic right
now right like we have to work towards
that um but I guess once you get that
latency to a point where it's even
across the board and you know what to
expect and you know what you know how
long your button prompts are gonna take
to show up and you're constantly playing
it it's fine so that's pretty much that
that's pretty much it man and of course
we have the Incredible Hulk of this aka
the XS gamer ooh the lord of combat
sports king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert move it Oh beloved Lord King how
you doing sir to this day to this day
boy I told you guys what was gonna go to
in that fight and Luis Ortiz King Kong
Luis Ortiz came in in best shape of his
life and he gave the best six rounds of
his life um until it was actually he
gave the best seven rounds of his life
Deontay Wilder tells you all the time
every time y'all gotta be perfect for 45
minutes I gotta be perfect for 2.5
seconds and he hit him with a bolt of
lightning
him down to jelly his body his spot and
this man crumbled into I always
disgusted by the ante well I mean I
don't like his his style whatever but I
knew the man has power the man has heart
mm-hmm and he looked disgusting
throughout that whole fight and him but
the best thing he threw was that right
cross it was perfect it was short it was
right to the point and when you saw the
sweat fly off of what it that it was it
was it was a sweat cleaner it was he was
slow they had that picture and they had
the picture of the life like I told you
guys how it was gonna go and if you
watched it it was beautiful because in
their first fight combat talk is up
right now guys please I love the Kings
talked up here
listen if you watched the first fight he
didn't catch him flush right this was in
and I've always said it if miss many
catches anybody flush on top of that
noggin it's over I don't know why his
chin was gonna air I don't know why he
took his eyes off the prize again we
have a heavyweight champion of the world
moving forward and now we got the we can
look forward to Joshua
versus Andy we a little unit could part
too
yes and um we're gonna see what happens
there well um it's week plan okay
I told you guys um remember that game
the last station
I told you guys in game crash I'm a game
past junkie and we have to cut you sir
we actually missed a super chat from Oh
Lord dizzy the $2.00 check King Oh soft
knees sorry you're healing it back early
all right so the last patient is up
right now and is its indie game that
made it to game past um for my TM Xbox
and I told you guys it's fantastic all
right so for you guys who don't have
game pads it's free this month if you
have games with gold okay right
download it check it out it's one of
those games that I'm trust me if you
like zombies if you like thrillers if
you like to you know story is made in a
16-bit format oh it's beautiful it's a
beautiful game they work very hard on it
and it's my suggestion well if you if
you ever seen a movie called train to
Busan it's a Korean Zombie movies sort
of the same it's a it's a train zombies
on a train you trying to get to a
certain place where supposedly you can
get away from it is reminiscent of that
oh yeah the lat the last station is very
cool so um I've been playing since game
pass decided to you know put out all
these great games range to is in there
I'm upset that I purchased that is in
there um also I've been shout out to the
great mr. bill Stilwell Oh
- lieutenant great brothers I am inside
X cloud oh yeah app what are you talking
about you're not in yes I didn't get no
notification I was just in it it was
like soon as XO hat
to the chat school to text talk my man
old school style trainer Busan is
awesome and then under guy tells you one
of the top-end easy play King David with
the good taste it gates that's what's so
beautiful game so more the game pass are
emojis in the chat yards so they're
saying oh yeah I don't hit that game pad
did we got them in there now so for the
game innocent so you know game pass has
a bunch of games out right now I've
downloaded Borderlands for the weekend
free there's so many programs that
they're doing guys even if you don't
have game pass you can definitely be
part of the ecosystem the free to play
weekend Borderlands is up plus it's all
I'm 33% off in an Xbox store go ahead
check that stuff out and um you know
have a good time because its games in
there like some of the games that we're
gonna talk about today that should be
highlighted all this uh award show stuff
it doesn't give a highlight and I have a
a good thought on how they can go
forward with these programs the
highlight a month every month they have
our award all know what games come out
for that month let's go
Sharpie PC master-race good morning
Lords you guys are one of the best
podcasts on the internet love you guys
they do love you back so Lucy arrests
I'm not in color K to be proud and of
course sorties gave a little bill it was
going to a deaf singles gonna and of
course we have the Lord the cooperative
experience and gaming injured himself
the shinobi spreading that realness in
the realm of the ILP not telling you
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear same deal as soft project X
cloud has some fantastic testing with
Chi Basu and addict as well I was doing
X cloud at work all my phone had a
Bluetooth headset I had maximum latency
I want to push it to the limit I like
Bluetooth headset Bluetooth could show I
wasn't even tethered to the joint I'm
doing Xbox Live party chat or sky he's
on he's at work remote console streaming
through X cloud from work into his xbox
and then addict is local on his PC
and we're all in party chat together
playing it and I'm just like wow this is
sorcery right now battling this is yeah
this is really cool and again I just got
to get out like a dedicated um you know
[ __ ] cuz I've been using the s9 and um I
just need like a dedicated headset that
you know goes into the standard port so
I can you know who it the traditional
way cuz I really want to eliminate as
much latency as possible you know during
that setup but to have me push it to the
limit that way and mine I'm gonna 4G
cellular bro LTE like that was crazy to
me so such a look to the team they out
here doing very well I'm liking what I'm
seeing and played a little bit of Jedi
fall in order and what else I think
that's pretty much a little bit uh
you've heard - oh yeah I did purchase at
their purchase definitely their purchase
I was had I had to do it man it was I
was here too many good things about it
so I want to purchase um my switch so
okay you're back well okay all plan I
want to start with Lord Steven his video
game system history his journey into the
games industry
and of course what led him to creating
to turn studios and the super promising
unto the end video game franchise so
loss leader let's start from the very
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you in the gaming so I got into gaming
my mom got me when I was like a maybe
seven years old
a Texas nutriment 99 which is like wow
I'd like a keyboard and like you know it
was like a not like a Cliquot vision or
like a the pirate was but it was similar
like Texas Instrument you know they
decided to make a game console mm-hmm he
had honey I don't know I can't remember
any of the games there were some
mountain-climbing game there's like a
pacman ripoff uh as soon as I started
playing that I just like fell in love
with games and I've kind of always been
interested in games ever since then mmm
I grew up as a Sega guy oh boy I looked
across the street from like these two
kids the same age as me and my brother
mm-hmm and they were endo guys oh yeah
right which consoles right you know you
could switch it the nest for the system
or whatever yeah it was a pretty
hardcore
say good guy so you man that bastard the
red and black console did you have any
did you have any little hue cards oh my
hero my hero
haunted house so you had that friend
that had the eddy yes but will you look
with you a little jealousy well you know
when you're it's weird like nowadays
with all the internet stuff you're so
you know what other games are out there
right and back in those days you just
kind of hear like oh Mario is a game or
you'd hear stuff and then you'd wonder
and you'd switch and then you you know
like when I got to play like punch-out
for example the first night or like
Zelda for the first time and like that
you're yeah I mean I I you fell in love
with those Apes too and they're like
huge inspiration for me you say though
mm-hmm and then I went like I kind of
went cold a little bit are not cold on
game from the consoles but like I didn't
play like I kind of missed the
PlayStation era and the place you era
okay so like a lot of games that like
all the crash bandicoot's like Bushido
blended all those games like I I need a
lot of those as a game designer but like
played a lot of them mm-hmm look more PC
games yeah
and also kind of like in the midst of
high school I think I was more
interested PC games like work regional
Warcraft and like Diablo and stuff for
like huge games originally and then like
cycled back into like you know consoles
and stuff like that with 360 I actually
worked at Microsoft like I was an intern
at Microsoft in one I went I joined
Microsoft after that and I remember we
got like Halo was really big Dan so
everyone was making halo it was a great
game but also it could play co-op right
now Mike everything Xbox is in every
conference like everyone so yeah we're
doing the land parties mm-hmm we plan
everyone's you know all the interns
around the same age you're just playing
like you know
all the time that is mostly I play on PC
now actually like I don't play just
certain I have like a like a smaller
little place I don't even have a TV so I
just play I play play my hair on my
desktop and stuff like that so yeah nice
veg salute salute to gaming history okay
interrupt you still got morning stuff no
no no yeah that's how that started
console thing over your other sister -
I'm gonna pay the bills don't ask a
couple more questions all shout - can't
do any fat stacks with - our super chair
I'm gonna leave game pass in my will for
my kids so you had you had that gap you
said Sega Master System whatever so what
was the last console before the gap of
you going away from gaming like was it
did you have the Genesis at all did you
after me well at Genesis tons of Genesis
games you know played a lot of Super NES
games um then like Dreamcast PlayStation
one we had my brother also he's two and
a half years hundred he's in games as
well he's a constant on here to war
actually oh you can see a lot of this by
guy it could talk we did a thing on him
where he did I guess icon and then like
I think so his stuff his feature the
Danton Lords are about dislike his game
stuff we always we always wanted to make
games so we kind of indifference many
different directions but yeah so then I
had a n64 was probably the last console
I owned gotcha
played like a ton of Goldeneye and like
you know 3d marios something like that
yeah and then didn't play for a bit and
then got back into it after it kind of
got done school and yeah so I'm nice
much make this history loving the
well-roundedness so on yeah I'm gonna
move on as far as now the career aspects
and then like getting into the game
English I know you said you you worked
at Microsoft for a little bit and then
um do some research yeah you did some
expansive stuff on all the azure portal
you're working on that and I didn't know
let's get to it man let's good job
difficult was it you know as far as tell
us about that process
you know you know obviously you know
starting that dream to kind of get into
game to chase your dream to get in the
game so let's get there yeah absolutely
so you know I I was at Microsoft about
12 years when I started Microsoft was
like a super serious place we're like
you it was it was much cooler than say
IBM IBM was like the stiff kind of
everyone Waratah and Microsoft even
shorts nice pretty serious I remember
when I was an intern I was working on
the team that doesn't exist anymore but
I one of the things I did was I I you
know I'm a designer so I I came up with
dia for tabbed browsing
like you know and I'm have tabs you know
and it's kind of like I came up with
that idea of Microsoft and I pitched my
managers and everyone guy said to me
he's like we don't invent things here
your job is to like do what we tell you
to do and not do stuff and I was like
wow this like I can't go without my
browser when I've had like in their
defense at that time the web browser was
a solved problem right like people were
like like they had like a handful of
people working on an air Explorer
there's no competition they thought
they'd won it's the browser wars with
Netscape Netscape oh my god with this
they would give you with me like ten
idol right and they thought they'd won
so they didn't you know when I had ideas
for like how to make the web browser
better they didn't care but you know
three years later then you know Firefox
came up with tabbed browsing and then
Chrome and then no now like the way to
go right um so I almost didn't even stay
at Microsoft I was like this place not
for me but I I did it around two
interviews after my internship mm-hmm
and I also got to meet Bill Gates and
it's like he was a pretty good guy he
actually has all the interns overdose
house for dinner that's nice
and it's his place is like museum it's
just like this really crazy it's almost
like in a way like a superhero
like layer they're like a mausoleum
desiring to I'm aspiring today but I was
lucky to join a team that did like a lot
of concept in work like they were
reinventing office and kind of cooling
okay and I stayed for 11 years doing
that stuff like always Microsoft the
calm like a v1 project so it's the first
generation of something where you're
trying to you know fit Forge basically
new ground in a new market or solve new
problems mm-hmm and so I did that and
then azure was the last thing I did
where I remember we started the team and
didn't have any real designers in it so
it was really kind of a bloodbath
getting getting people that are very
technical to understand the role of
designers mm-hmm and kind of carving out
an area for design but yeah the last
project I worked on was was really a
rethinking of Windows yeah we you know
doing it kind of in a in a way that
focus more on professionals like Windows
is kind of this great ubiquitous thing
but um then algae I don't know if this
will resonate with you guys but the
analogy was look if you're in the army
like and you're a GI like a standard
infantry guy you get the standard kit
right like you get everybody same boom
Banta stuff if you're part of the force
like you can kind of decide whatever you
want right you're like I'm wearing out
and climbing food so I'm gonna wear a
bike helmet I'm gonna use this weapon
and we you know the big thought was like
look Windows is great because it catered
to all these people but if I'm gonna
spend you know eight ten hours a day
crafting art or making movies or
whatever I should have a suite of tools
and an operating system that is really
customizable for me that I can earn and
make you know my own because of the way
I work force to say someone like my
brother just cuz games doesn't mean we
worked actly the same way exactly okay
the last project I did but that really
helped me like that always being on the
frontier of like thinking of new ideas
and innovate and trying to our
differentiation within projects I think
set me up well to do games absolutely
and creative aspects so I mean I guess
my question for you in reference to the
the Microsoft days for you I think
obviously it helped you help mold you
but did you feel it restricted you it
kind of limited you in that box where
where it's gaming kind of allowed you to
spread your wings on the creative side
yeah I mean gaming I think a little bit
yeah like I I think if
talk any of my colleagues back Microsoft
they would be like all yeah that guy he
was not a guy I definitely like to
challenge convention and and you know
I'm very proud of some of the things we
did at Microsoft and some of the add-ins
and stuff that I've received but I think
gaming for me is it's the ultimate
creative medium you have to bring
together so many different skills I
think I was really shocked after sir
Sara left choose an interior designer oh
wow
she left her business and I left
Microsoft and you know I had a I had
really did have like a dream job I was a
concept architect and ran a team of like
designers and just kind of ran around
coming up with ideas but I left that job
and I thought you know I hit the ground
running and you know twelve months later
a game out and I was really surprised I
maybe I don't know I I think it was it's
definitely been harder than I thought it
would be but yeah I kind of knew at the
back of my mind that to do something
really great would be hard anyway yeah
but I think the number of skills you
have to bring together like animation
art storytelling you know pacing
fundamentals of game design like a sonic
experience mm-hmm you know I think just
Matt it's a lot of black arts and games
I don't think people appreciate like
something as simple as like game feel
like when you move a character left and
right yes jump and stuff like that that
is like there are some cool books like
actually book called game feel by Steve
Swank but so that you know like getting
that right like we said I really did
Bend like probably about a year just
would like the little guy in a room and
back and forth the springboard just to
get a feel appropriate you know and he
knows and deliberate and stuff like that
and so I think I took that for granted
how much work it takes you know
absolutely I mean again not easy man
want to give some shoutouts and check
Kersh gaming Stevens my hero
shut up to a tip diamond the to our
super chat salute the iron law panel hit
that like button
big crowd I see you yeah Matt this is
actually a perfect segue because you
know when you mentioned in taking that
leap of faith now you know you're Sarah
now going and then forming your own
studio you know say so I want to get to
that and then just obviously you know
2-ton has a you
dynamic because obviously it's a
husband-and-wife team so I wanted to
kind of touch on that as well
you know the advantages and
disadvantages of that and just you know
what was those steps now to say okay
let's do it let's make a studio and
let's really go hard and make in our own
game sure let me do I don't know if
that's if Gersh is the guy I used to
work with at Microsoft food is it goes
it says gosh I don't know yeah it was a
great guy
he and I work together at Microsoft and
uh lame I actually mentored him and you
know he's an intern when I was a little
bit more senior so I saw him grow and go
through his career and know very he says
yup it's me you know in terms of forming
two times Studios Sarah and I left with
we knew we kind of felt like we had the
skills to make something interesting but
we we also went in with it into it with
a very I guess artists mindset of hey
you know like let's try and do something
that we think's interesting mm-hmm but
if it fails that's okay you know like
there's a lot of super talented people
out there there's a lot of people with
really great ideas and also sometimes
the games that you know Sarah and I'd
like aren't necessarily the games that
are the most popular and never you try
to do something on your own you're
always weighing like financially yes you
know it can you make this into something
viable versus creatively it might be
interesting and those things aren't
always the same correct correct and so
you know we went through this journey of
for the first well we packed up like I
my job Sarah left her solder commed oh
wow this is hot that we made gloss over
this thing now you're just glossing over
like really go off for your dream bro
like this is truly inspirational like
you guys had your heart set this is what
we're gonna do that that's amazing
continues yeah I mean I guess I gloss
over cuz it's now like five years ago
but yeah we we had a great house in
Seattle a condo that really like we
loved a great job Sarah had a great job
with a good community of friends but I
think we felt that something was missing
in a sense of we'd kind of done what we
wanted to do and our we thought we'd
done as much as we could do in the roles
we were in we want to challenge
ourselves ridin
and a little bit if it came down to like
we want to have kid God you know and
then wanna stop and have kids and then
start a family or do we want to go and
try and you know take one more shot at
kind of doing this we decided to do the
you know we decided to pack it all up
and travel mm-hmm we just did a ton of
like concept thing I think we built like
seven or eight game concepts to learn
you know like how to make games to get
mattered and some of those are well
realized and some are terrible but and
then I guess we it was our travels in
northern Scotland and in Iceland that
really kind of concretize the idea of
hey let's make a game about like a
normal guy that's struggling through a
harsh environment and about him trying
to overcome these these this world
that's bigger than him and these
challenges that are bigger than him in
order to get you know that eventually
became a story about getting back home
version it was a story of revenge but
really to overcome these challenges that
are bigger than him bike you didn't want
to make a game where the main character
is too heroic like he's not you know
like you you have a lot of games like
you know a god of war with Kratos and
stuff like that word you know he's a
he's a demigod like you warriors yeah
and you know and you have games where
you're the chosen one or mmm-hmm we want
to kind of buck that trend where a lot
of the things in the game you come
across it's events where you have no
choice but to you know fight or you know
or you you come across you know
architecture and stuff like that much
bigger and grander than you and we
wanted to make the father feel kind of
small um a little bit like I think like
what the Coen brothers do you know in
some of their movies like No Country for
Old Men right like you know like Josh
Brolin is like he's kind of the hero but
he's also just kind of this guy that
falls into this situation and tries to
make the best of it and at the end
you're kind of like a little bit you
know you don't really happen to the guy
there's in this clean resolution and we
kind of like that kind of storytelling
where you if you took like two weeks of
someone's life you kind of you know
tried to show that that's kind of frying
me
you change this you're perfect cuz
that's literally what I was about to ask
you it was just about the main event why
we are here you're gonna say this game
that we obviously are seen in 2017 and
um you know to be completely honest we
said this offline you know it was
something I was hunting down for a while
I remember first seeing that trailer and
completely blown away by cinematic the
the atmospheric elements and um you know
it was just something again as a fan of
a person who played inside especially
first feel was out of this world where
there's no black yes it's mr. black and
this saw what was cool like I love those
games where there's no narration and
then like the atmosphere telemental
storytelling yeah yeah storytelling it
was just the grunts and everything
music everything and again it's one of
those things and I think there was a
scene specifically that reminds me I was
like no I don't show you get off the
water or you don't know what's going on
and you see kind of like the low the
wild world the black well to be so
whatever that bring in and you like oh
what's that and his body's like do I
miss the games where it don't hold your
hand and literally - were done - yet
like I've seen it and then you see one
of those creatures from another race
looking at you know the main torment
looking guy and then what was different
was I thought it was gonna be more so
like on the inside tip but when I saw
the combat and I'm like wait a minute
you know say and then it's like there's
parrying and it's faking and I'm like oh
there's a fighting system here like this
this is so dis I wanted to get into that
because it's a huge departure from the
other two in that respect because you
have that aspect and then it also be
where punch-out fans
I thought of punch-out I thought of like
you got your black hi-low you know
timing all that stuff so let's get into
that like the thought process about
designing a game in that fashion and
it's just a huge departure from
obviously the Metro of Aeneas and you
know the great Souls likes kind of thing
let's get it to that part yeah so I mean
III think 2d although there's a lot of
2d games I still think it is you know a
side-on view is still one of the the
quintessential video game views that
gives you an experience that you can't
really replicate in real life like even
though I first version and you know over
the shoulder
it's great I think that it's something
that it comes close to real life in many
ways right like I can walk through a
forest and kind of feel a little bit
like I might be in like death stranding
or something Judy I think it's really
unique so you know we want to make
something like that I I also like and it
kind of leaving Microsoft the minimal UI
design was kind of a very big and kind
of frightening and so I kind of
influenced some of my art I would say
and definitely sarazar so so trying to
capture that we also really wanted to
capture the feel maybe justice invited
you talking sincere when someone asked
you like how to unwind your creative
thinking so it's gone but my brother
being a concept artist and always liking
concept art and concept art like it
tends to give you the impression of a
scene without the details right leg
enough detail for you to get a feel and
of the mood in the phone but it doesn't
worry about like you know the little
intricacies that you might have if you
fully rendered the thing mm-hmm
you want to capture that feel for people
where we try to keep the art stylized
enough so you know what's going on but
also abstract enough so you can pour
yourself into the experience right up
you know so you can kind of imagine what
the emotions are without as nice with
others forcing you know you to think a
certain way
Oh in the combat system itself really
evolved from us doing a lot of
prototyping and kind of testing things
out but kind of coming to these insights
around what makes to be really special
so I'm a big believer I've always felt
this way at Microsoft whenever I trying
to take on something that if you're
gonna do something you know Steve Jobs
would have said we'll just do it
different because you know we're Apple
we do it different but but I think of it
more as do it do it differentiate it so
think about what makes your medium
really unique and build a set of systems
around that uniqueness so for me into DD
things you can do that you can't really
do in 3d is judge left and right
distance right and low and be able to
see behind you yes right needs are
things like 3d you know like Dark Souls
if it suffers from everything is like
one the camera gets in your way
- very hard to like Steve around you you
know and you often get you know what
kind of you get cheaply killed by
finding ya cuz you're fighting with the
camera you can't I completely
we dealt with it and then so you know if
you go like old school God of War you
don't have to I can't see behind myself
problem but you can't really judge
height anymore like you're really
restricted almost to like like if you if
you d if you deconstruct God of War it's
really like asteroids right like an
ottoman where it's like asteroids and
you're just trying to like keep guys off
you yes and it that's threats and take
the next guy and so we hadn't seen a
game that had done 2d combat that really
put the three things together like you
know Street Fighter definitely does a
lot of high-low and zoning yes right but
you know you don't really fight multiple
guys and so we thought those three
elements would make for a really
interesting system and then we layered
on you know the ability to use friendly
fire right like we I love emergence and
games like I was just playing blood
routes the you know I don't know you
guys know that game it's another indie
game but they it's all it's all about
picking up these obstacles and then
throwing them at people like you can
pick up a tire and like roll in it you
can pick up a firecracker
fire and it's all about like emergent
gameplay gotcha and so I love when you
can kind of feel smart by doing things
mMmmm in the game world and then you
have these aha moments like oh man I can
use like a guy who throws spears against
another guy or whatever the case may be
and then the Train we thought was
interesting like being able to use like
walls and knock guys off cliffs and
opponents that could follow you where
you go like a lot of games you know
especially the old guys like Castlevania
the guys they were they were top guys
they were smack just run off the edge
and kill themself yeah walked on a
platform when they run back and forth
mhm and that's fine I mean in certain
cases you want it can jump and follow
you and you know climb after you and on
this game you know kind of have that
like action movie kind of feel like if
you watch like die hard like he doesn't
just spend all this time fighting on one
you know Bruce will spend all this time
like fighting on one box guys their wall
and then goes into the next room and I
move laying it as we want to kind of
have moments you know like that so yeah
I think we really just tried to make
something differentiated based on a
perspective a view that we thought was
neat and that really hadn't been done
before no though let me ask you - ow -
oh boy can't daddy fast axe he said does
unto the end have a good level of
difficulty
I think so what do you good you know I
don't I guess that it's always
interesting the difficulty question is
always interesting because I think I
sarin I like to think of it as not
difficult but challenging and so let me
kind of qualify that a bit so I think
things are difficult when no matter how
skillful you are how much you practice
with something you can still die
unexpectedly yeah and so to me that is
not a kind of game that they can be
frustrating that kind of difficult I
think a MS that is challenging is a game
that when you when you get good with it
new encounters are are demanding because
they're novel not because the role like
they drop anvils on your head and you
and under the end is a very challenging
game in the sense that we consistently
throw the father in just into situations
that are bigger and kind of unexpected
and then we we leave it to the player to
unwind those things yes figuring out
figure out how to kind of overcome them
in an in a quote/unquote easy way so I
would say difficulty you know to use the
more kind of generic term difficulty we
would say like a punch-out kind of thing
I don't know if people punch out
difficult right I don't think it's as
punishing as say like a Dark Souls I
think okay I love dark souls i think
Dark Souls is mmhmm maybe other people
think it's as punishing as Dark Souls
but we have a save model like hyper
light drifter okay so our idea was not
to make it so that I mean are you
starting us back at the beginning of the
level really we got that's what they
wanna know me I think I think so you
don't have to do that I think I think I
think darks was a great brilliant game
and I think it's model works really well
but for us we wanted every enemy to be
unique okay so like a punch-out fight
you know not in a boss rush way but
every encounter and the collection of
enemies makes up a unique encounter and
they have a reason for being there in
the story Dark Souls falls a little bit
more of a model where you're
encountering mobs of characters that are
waiting for you it's more like running
exalt over and over yes
and and unto the end was more about kind
of that play dad kind of model more even
for school you know under the world or
flash where they're telling you a story
based on the environment and the
encounters with those creatures you know
they make sense for the world like
they're not just like waiting for you
they're often surprised you're even
there yes and you you know react to your
presence aggressively because they're
like who is this human you know it's
like maybe I want to stop you for a
second good at it you talk it was that
it always enjoyed games that I would
like the two dot types of difficulty
when what I think a games there's
difficulties like you know games that
are built around those challenges in
mind then there's difficulties like
let's just give everyone more health
make them take more damage make them do
more damage you like I feel like that's
artificial difficulty that's not
challenging it's frustrating mm-hmm
there's something like something like
you know stuff that's made in with the
souls formerly like that was designed to
be challenging it wasn't designed to be
difficult like like you know like we we
don't have any inflated like health
pools you know like we don't have bought
fights that have like you know love you
know this guy's gonna take 50 hits to
kill and we try to make it much more
like a Bushido blade or or a like a you
are bad if you're skilled you know you
can you can defeat every enemy pretty
easily like our kind of model is what a
we play we have to be able to beat every
opponent and every encounter without
taking any hits and be able to do it in
multiple ways got you do that then it's
too hard gosh you know oh it really feel
easy for me to go through it and play it
because I'm finding these guys no but
for someone going through it for the
first time it should feel you know
challenging and demanding and hopefully
enjoyable so that's the kind of balanced
wrench strike it's like the darks those
games you could beat them really fast
but the first time you play them it's
kind of take you a long time thank you
super well yeah yeah absolutely so I
want to touch on some because you
started deep-dive with it in a sense of
these two things obviously we saw some
behind the scenes things that were
pretty impressive
yeah salud Aloha Stephen for that I was
amazing um I guess the thing that I
wanted to talk about in reference to the
game was that two parts one I didn't
realize that in this game you had the
ability to avoid combat with the other
races and there are certain things that
you can do that kind of lead to that
which is kind of cool I've never I
didn't I didn't think this game had that
dynamic on matter what taught me about
that process you know and kind of
incorporating that into a game like this
sure yeah yeah hey thanks a lot guys by
the way um yeah so we wanted to make
again a story about a father you know
he's not he's not a mark he's not a
murderer he's not that he's not a no
he's got it out there to go and slay a
lot of guys out of anger he's really
just trying to find the fastest way home
right oh and he happens to go through
these situations where he needs to fight
but there we wanted to kind of make it
so that the creatures you're fighting
some of them are just as smart if not
smarter than you they have just as much
culture and background they have lives
and families like you do there's this
quote where it's like every time you
meet someone mm-hmm you know they're
fighting a battle that you know nothing
about life and I think it's very like
why can't it be true in games true why
why did these creatures you fight why
did he just have to be these mindless
automatons why can't they also be
worried about one wanna precoat wrecking
their children or whatever a there's a
specific see with that guy I love that
in the game where we we allow you to we
definitely allow you to fight and that's
to us part of the agency we give the
player that's won twice makes it feel
like it's your story versus our story
being told to you and and then we allow
you to in certain cases be peaceful you
can put your sword away and walk by or
you can actually offer up some of your
your resources that you've gathered to
help them out yes and then there's also
kind of these knock-on effects where
you'll get certain items either
exploration or from other characters and
then you can use those you can give
those other characters and so there's
you know these Forks and the road so to
speak with respect to the narrative
mm-hmm
that get impacted based on these
decisions and ultimately kind of the how
the game kind of concludes and and
really who the father is when he gets
back to his fam
like I don't know why this pops to mind
but there is like all those old jail
movies like in the 80s like one with Tom
Selleck and back to their family you
know like they're there and they
fundamentally changed yeah
and so I would imagine a father who you
asked to like you know fight his way
through these you know foreign lands
would come back to his family and be you
know like you would coming back from war
you would probably be a changed person
and will your you know your wife and
daughter will they recognize you anymore
and will you even want to you know be a
father anymore is it's kind of a
question we ask and and we allow that to
play out based on the players's two more
questions with the with before unto the
end as far as one thing I like that you
guys that you don't have any health bar
and a traditional rifle everything is
based on the feel of your main cattle
our column torment my god torment sure
yeah so like I seen certain states right
you know he's healthy he's upright he's
fine
then you kind of got okay he's a little
damaged heavy breathing then I haven't
seen that the one knee kind of bended
knee a little bit you know so like tell
me about that and then like getting your
character you know the things you could
do to get your character you know life
back or whatever shout outs a car go by
they don't also back to circle I know
she's not here I wanted to ask like
what's her specific role with on today
like what are the things that she's
responsible for in conjunction with you
sure yeah so you know of course stuff
I'll tackle first so there's this kind
of principle in UI design called the
foci of attention with things like what
I'm working on something you can see
this like in movies it happens there
when you're working at something you
tend to kind of get like tunnel vision
and it's things get more intense focus
more on the the things that matter most
you right you've probably psychological
studies were like a guys shooting three
throats yes and you know the
psychologists like okay count the number
of balls to go on the net and then like
a guy in a gorilla suit like runs in the
background and you know that's all like
foci of attention stuff and so we wanted
take it so that the players focus needs
to be on the hero the main character and
the opponent and you know putting like
you eye around the fringes now divide
your
okay so now ya go back and forth
greediness these things mm-hmm
and also it's interesting like a lot of
what we're doing riding is interesting
trying to push back or put push aside
maybe your divert like 20 or so years of
convention mm-hmm as to what it means to
make a game about a guy with a sword
right who's fighting things right so a
lot of the assumptions coming in are
okay it's gonna be fast pace you're
gonna be fighting large number of his
enemies it's or about the individual
path like a dead cells is a really good
collation of acts I like that solve like
that that's right but but dead cells is
a game works very fast-paced every enemy
has a specific thing they do well and
it's learning that thing and then
figuring out the different you know how
to use your different capabilities
versus those things and I think dead
cells is really a master work and
movement and and pacing and stuff like
that but unto the end is not that at all
like it's very different not but when
people come into a game if their if
their expectations are not aligned
correctly they won't enjoy it so we have
these things like make it so that you
know we have this thing like you roll
off a cliff you'll you'll fall
face-first and drop your sword and I let
me do that because because we want to
show you like look man movement is is a
deliberate thing you have to pay
attention what you're doing in this game
right but if you're holy and jump up and
hit your head you're like an actor head
and hurt yourself and then drop your
sword and so you can kill yourself by
smashing your head against the head
trauma the head shot about this day to
buy a story but I the point is what
we're trying to push that tide away and
part of it is getting rid of the HUD and
and making it so that you know blood is
on the hero because the most important
skill in the game to develop as a player
is the ability to observe and read and
react to the threats in the world yes
look at your environment kind of in the
macro level and see how you could use
that to your advantage and then a micro
level be able to look at an opponent and
see if they're attacking high or low or
they know that you know faking me you're
bashing me or whatever so it just made
sense to kind of keep everything
focused in that way so Sara's rolled out
the wife yes well I think Sara and I are
100% a team on this we really
collaborate on all aspects so Sara is I
always say a much more natural artist
than me like I consider myself more of
kind of an inventor designer with art
skills where sara is really like a pure
artist like if she lived you know back
in the days of DaVinci shoot like you
just have can't find so um but we do
collaborate a lot of this stuff like we
both do the artwork nice Sara tends to
do more of the outdoor spaces I tend to
do more the indoor spaces okay Oh God
Sara is better at natural art like take
like a lot of our gameplay is inspired
by hikes and stuff we've done and trust
that feeling of being lost but kind of
like humbling to find your way mm-hmm I
think that natural kind of beauty and
compositions there's a lot better at
stuff I like a little bit more of the
indoor things I'm definitely much more
of a nerd kind of geek than Sara okay
what I got a character designs what
about like I love the torment card you
got the cloak you have there even that
the wife and child like it kind of play
it or their relationship with the wife
it's a big way definitely there's a
little bit of that yeah okay they're
definitely a lot fiercer and probably if
we were in martial times it's the
beefed-up version of young okay but yeah
I mean we everything but there is
nothing we do in the game that isn't
like I mean you were only two people to
write so when you have a small you
really don't have a choice but we also
yeah we really play off each other you
know like I'll often like start a
concept and then Stara will like give me
notes and then all iterate or Sara will
like work on an environment and be like
what about this kind of a feel of like
say a forest then I'll give her feedback
so it did goes back and forth I would
say the one thing that is really good is
that Sara it likes games but she's not
like a super hardcore gamer right if
she's able to look at game things and
say I don't know why like for her a
health bar is not like an obvious thing
like she's like we need a health bar
like why is that the way you have to do
it right
okay gotcha why do you have to make for
example like you know you could argue
like why don't we show like damage
points when the guy gets hit right hmm
like to Sarah that that's not a thing
that she cares about she would never
like that's not an obvious thing right
it's only you're kind of indoctrinated
in games zero I'm like the weight of
course you're thinking if that's
supposed to do we really like challenged
these things and think about them from a
kind of creative artistic perspective
without being bogged down by some of the
ice good yeah and I think I tend to be a
little bit more like like I wake up
pretty much every morning and say hey I
had an idea
mm-hmm and then you know we'll be like
okay and what she's good at like looking
at an idea and saying like that's
baloney like I would say like
relationship-wise done anything with a
significant other advice and I was about
to ask you it is like that push like a
whole day and then you know someone
comes and says I don't know - I don't
know like I watch a lot of British Bake
Off I don't know you guys watch that
show but like someone's trying to make
like a horse or something then guys will
come by and be like what is that as a
seal and then like you can see them like
deflated yeah that's kind of the thing
right like I'm working you know I'll be
working on it on some attack animation
and this arrow say something like I
don't know it looks like he's punching
the guy or something guys and and that
cooks like the first couple times that
happens you just like crushed right you
really are but you realize that you need
that feedback and it has to be
unvarnished and and you have to get it
from someone you respect the level of
honesty that you're working with each
other that makes it better because you
know she has your best interest at heart
so she wants you to shine at your best
so when you're doing this you understand
I can respect her opinion of it and
maybe it does look stupid let me fix
this part right here because you know
how honesty is coming through so and you
trust each other it's about trust
how do % yeah like I I have to think
back to like you know George Lucas
making the prequels and at that point he
was like a god you know like ever mmm
you're good and I don't think anyone
who's willing to say like I don't know
George like this
one he had people that were like you
know would tell them honestly what they
thought and I think that is really you
know it makes a big difference it Kojima
syndrome actually snuck away from IOP
just to take a look at the trailer for
us it's a beautiful game guys I can't
like when he said and you can see it too
the collaboration between the two the
outdoors what he said is her strength
let her play to her strength because he
acknowledges that's not his strength and
it shows like and then you go to the
inside looks as equally as good as the
outside because that's his strength and
he played to his strengths the animation
it's I can't wait you know I really
can't wait
realm is very hype they're doing it
research like what is this game these
guys talk about but I want to now
transition now to what I call a magic
moment bring it back man so it's been my
328 329 you know I'm saying and
obviously Microsoft had a huge presence
at a huge show they were the only one
there this year but um we saw at the a
little vignette you know say and there
it was on to the end debuting on the
Xbox press briefing stage so I just want
to ask you Leslie like how did it feel
to get to call for Microsoft to be
selected like this is literally the
Super Bowl of gaming and your game is
included and a vision that onstage you
like tell me the fives what was the
thought process at that point I mean
it's kind of its kind of surreal right
especially when you hear about it and
you're like okay that you know like
you're you you you get ready kind of
like mentally prepare you know okay I'm
gonna watch this thing on stage you're
very proud you I mean make it as I said
earlier I think like making a game is an
incredibly hard thing to do and and
Sarah died you know really been working
like crazy on this thing so when you get
acknowledgement for from kind of an
industry leader you feel
all a degree of vindication ready mm-hmm
is like also this weird rollercoaster
though because you and the same thing
kind of happened with getting just back
from egx like you get you go to these
things or you have these moments and you
feel amazing right you're like wow we've
really accomplished this thing but then
you kind of come down you're like okay
we start the finished yeah it is
draining mentally but yeah like having
getting the call from Microsoft was a
huge really uh you know like yeah really
validated or like all of our hard work I
think is it pressure now is it pressure
doubt it you got the call they recognize
the greatness but now it's like you're
we really gotta deliver now you Phil
don't you don't say like everyone back
to chuck up now likes is it pressure
though I think there's a bit of that but
I also think like Sarah and I put a ton
of pressure on ourselves to make
something we're extremely proud of like
you know I don't want it at the end of
this thing be done and be like I just
made a game you know like I don't want
to make a game that people really think
like I don't need everyone loved it I
don't think that's impossible but right
well I want to make a game when people
play it it does feel like a really
unique experience and really Sarah and I
feel like yeah we we put it you know as
far as we could of and so that kind of
pressure comes from we it with in seeing
it onstage in the moment having like you
know Keanu Reeves come out like having
our little game part of its real then
that's like a moment where like I often
think like if I went back and told like
you know 15 year old me but that's gonna
happen you know listen Laura kognito
went absolutely nuts yeah I think I like
yeah I was pretty mixed acog neato
and and and as soon as it came up in the
trailer I feel his or his hand on my arm
like good this is like you know you make
a discovery we go over these game shows
you know and we find games that we like
we talk amongst each others you what
gave me like the most well I like this
game over here and what we like to do is
drag each other to the game
we like the most yes so we will drag
each other to it and we'll see a game
and we just hope the rest of the world
can get a piece yes
or get a glimpse of this game then maybe
not too many people know about yeah so
since I see your game that he saw some
place in his heart on the screen yeah
yeah wet means a ton
the wait is for me it's like you know
when the Lord's we all go attic solve
all that we go to these shows and
especially like a pax or something like
that to me that's more like like that's
the grassroots that's okay you finish
your now showing it all for the first
time so you have these little gems and
it for me it's like it's like sports so
it's like if that was that was my little
draft pick maybe they've got they got
the cold I got the call to the big
leagues they're like oh I remember
that's why I bid because at the end of
the day is like you know again you know
not to go too deep but remember when you
know our toda I lost track of you guys I
remember when I first came across the
game 2017 I'm like wow this looks
amazing right and then I just wanted to
ask you about that period because there
was kind of period you guys went dark
for a little bit and I didn't know what
happened and I'm like okay did I seen
the book big sugar come in and I'm like
okay maybe they got we picked up or my
okay and then the bombshell it's like oh
this is Micah so this is now a game past
this is like yo we out here that so like
tell us that process because again there
was a period where you went away so I
just wanted to know you know what was
going on during that process yeah I mean
it was a it was a tougher time I would
say like there was kind of two aspects
of that one we originally signed with a
publisher called digerati
yes and did you Rotti then became
digital uppercut yes yes that I was
actually part of like I was not super
well-known but I was actually part of
that Wow like the reason I joined that
like there was four guys myself got a
nick Matt and Chris [ __ ] we started you
cut oh wow it was gonna be kind of like
um yeah like a sister label to the
digerati stuff that's right and the end
was gonna be one of the first games
there's a couple other games that were
coming out for that mm-hmm and there
were some ups and downs with that I
think balancing
locating into too much detail because of
you probably feel trouble but then there
was a job and then also we had we had a
developer working with us so Sara and I
were able to focus on the art and we had
a developer working with us and he had
he was a you know a an X Microsoft guy
had retired a very smart guy started
tons of startup you know companies and
he worked at Microsoft for a while but I
think we underestimated how important
that feel for games is yes you know he
was a very talented programmer mm-hmm
but that feel for games was not
something he was really passionate about
he didn't really have her and so we
ultimately had to part ways and in doing
that we threw away about a year's worth
of work that's what happened Wow
like the in that fall of when the heck
was that 2018 of us deven 2018 now scour
and million I couldn't find you had to
make a decision like okay what are we
gonna do here right like we didn't want
to take his code for because I can
create all these IP issues down the road
social network or something so it was
like okay am I gonna rewrite this whole
game engine from scratch or are we gonna
find someone else whatever so oh I mean
I have a computer science background but
I'm not well I mean first admit I'm not
the world's greatest programmer I don't
like I know really brilliant programmers
I'm not one of them right but I I'm
confident enough with programming and I
have a lot of passion that I can kind of
figure it out yeah so I decided to
rewrite the engine myself and so then he
stayed in unity yeah I stayed in unity
and you know wrote the thing in c-sharp
and mm-hmm
that was about eight months of work and
so then that kind of gets us to like you
know on the path where we are now but
yeah we have to do almost we had some of
the art and and a lot of the animations
in kind of levels blocked we had to do a
pretty big reboot mmm when that dev left
yeah and then the big thing was big
sugar decided the guy who runs that
decided to stop digital uppercut and
started a new play ball I don't really
know what the reasoning for that was but
yeah that it's still the same company
the whole time a publisher oh but it's
Ben yeah it's gone through some changes
in terms of branding and vision and
stuff like that that is tremendous man
you got that decision must have been
extremely hard because you had all this
work that was done and to just delete
and start from scratch that must have
been a serious conversation you know
going through it was really tough it's
it's like um
and it's there's a lot of you see these
graphs right like making a game is like
you start out and everything's great
then you go into this like dark valley
of like well I get what you're doing and
then you kind of come out and that would
be like the darkest of valleys where it
was very much and what are we doing like
what mm-hmm
you know you also have to add on like we
sold our house left our young yeah
we're living out of a suitcase at that
time like we were in South America and
we're like what the hell I have a theory
that you can only take on as a human so
many unknowns right so we know we had no
idea like you know what's our future
gonna be like we had no idea where we're
going to live didn't we work out this
project it didn't seem to have any
future and so I don't know I I think to
make do something like that yes we'll be
a little bit nuts
I think optimism to a degree but I guess
we leaved in it enough mmm I'm to try it
and then yeah I think it kind of it just
started working and and you know the
fact that I was writing it it actually
made it better I thought because it it's
it's whenever you work on something
whenever you defer an idea it his heart
lane to someone else
yes be hard to make sure like you know
if we were say trying to do mm-hmm
let's say we're trying to like a contra
like entre and may can make it like with
a sword or something right easier for
someone to wrap their head around but if
we're trying to make a game that doesn't
really have an existing at a model it's
it's harder people to build off of and
make it turned out to be the right
decision for me to do all that program
but if I never have to program again
after you come full circle Wow let me
tell you man that is really inspiring
you know I'm saying I think yeah I
didn't realize how how it got how how
low it got
and just to see you guys turn this thing
around take control of your vision you
know and then again like I said to me
the the magic moment like I said you get
this is the like the ultimate love story
yeah I'm just sitting here like this
yeah yeah took y'all was successful in
your careers yeah had to have to sit
down and talk about okay let's ditch
this career should we have a family or
sure we tried to just finish this one
last accomplishment together yeah
decided that together y'all went on this
journey together you know went into that
valley together and you came out of that
valley together with these decisions
together and y'all are on this stage you
see your baby on this stage together and
I'm telling you that that bond must be
super incredible because y'all wanting
trials and tribulations you went from
having it all to having nothing to going
back up that ladder to having it all and
that is a beautiful beautiful story not
everybody has the courage to pursue
precisely what they want in life it's
difficult because you know when you have
something that's safe relatively savor
it's it's difficult to up and say hey no
I don't want these I want what I want
we don't like to be uncomfortable Yeah
right that's a belief for the dream so I
just want to now get in today we
appreciate you for coming and telling
your story this is amazing um I want to
get into now the the gay past enemy you
know and um obviously you know you let
me tell you each and every one of these
millions and millions of people are
going to get a chance to play yo baby
this is this is it this is it let's get
to the game pass out the cat daddy I see
I see I see the chat I've seen a lot of
chat with the emoji so it's gonna today
because um obviously you know it was one
thing to see the game ID at Xbox a you
know it's great program saluting the
indie developers getting some shine on
the big city that's one thing but now
we're like no this is game past as well
cuz you you're also multiplayer but good
at before you were all type
you still are correct yes right but at
this point you go boom now it's in-game
pass on Xbox most likely they date you
know on release so tell us about that
dynamic in if you feel that helps you as
a developer yeah so uh just a clip yeah
we're on all platforms you know that all
the consoles and steam and then day one
on Xbox for sure like that'll be our
first thing we can't be on as if there
was a like Sony has their own like you
know right based service we couldn't be
also on that for a period of time okay
yeah so the honestly the Xbox thing was
just amazing man like I we met those
guys at Gamescom we did hosed or kind of
like press all names can we drop some
names or some names Charlie come on now
wait around oh my if you could drop a
day that would be appreciative back at
Nick Nick suka which is a great guy and
then also like from the marketing side
so those are the two guys we met it was
Sarah and I and then one guy from our
publisher that chatted with them nice
and I was it was a pretty surreal
experience because they come in there I
games Khan was behind closed door you're
doing your meeting press and you're
telling about the game every 30 minutes
right so it's like 30 minutes on 30
minutes off and this is going on for
three days and so you're you're you're
losing your voice you're trying to
always come with a maximum amount of
energy under your pitch and I never
wanted to know who we were talking to
right like because I didn't want to know
I didn't want to like you know I don't
work really hard to for like Rock Paper
Shotgun but then like not give as much
energy to someone to write and also I
didn't want to get nervous - nervous but
I was talking right so anyway and they
were like just so impressed with what
we've done like they look beautiful they
were they didn't they were kind of like
like you guys like this they'd seen the
2017 stuff mm-hmm
to be kind of like an inside limbo kind
of maybe a little more story puzzle
driven opened up that demo with the
combat you know
the mother luggage bar yes love that
would blown away like they really like
we're like holy smokes like this was way
more depth than we thought they were
they were kind of throwing all these
accolades at us right have that happen
from like from a you know like I think
Xbox that idea is a fantastic program
and I think xbox arcade which is [ __ ]
on two three six the backbone of like
that indie game the movie mm-hmm um so I
have those guys like say hey this is
really great I think yeah I don't know
it's hard to put into words or they
really help Sara and I feel like wow
what we're doing is worthwhile and all
those risk it was very emotional to be
honest like you you do something
different you get people or like I don't
know that's ridiculous like no one why
don't you just do this other thing and
it's easier and blah blah and some of
the people that are telling you that are
pretty close to you you know it's not
[ __ ] man I treat telling you like your
idea isn't working like sometimes like
it's like people that you respect are
telling you like this might not work
Wow and so when someone like Xbox comes
along and says hey we believe in this
you know they actually had one thing
we're the like why do you want to be
famous the guy asked me so like do you
want to be famous and I was like I said
no I was like no I that's not of
interest to me
and then the gut my publisher guy was
like yes I felt like the right answer
it was truthful that's not my goal being
like but you want your game to be
remembered yeah absolutely like if I can
if we can make something and people say
like wow undo the ending that was an
experience that really stood out for me
you know among up variances or that
really challenged kind of my perception
of what a to DM could be your nose but
whatever like to me the beautiful thing
about games is they can give you these
these experiences at last view for a
lifetime and I think that those don't
come along that often really so I would
be lucky enough to like make a game here
I would be amazing
it's immortality yeah in a way it did
yeah yes because when when you make this
staple it's a staple when you make
and your game reverberates in this
community because children are being
born every day yeah right and they're
going to play games games are going to
be played in to the ends of time and
when your game is mentioned in the name
of my Amato and these icons these
pillars and they mention you in your
game you want to be immortalized famous
No Fax so I'm mortal eyes yes so yes
what it did touch back into the into the
game past portion like yeah so then how
do you feel do you feel that helps you
as a development yeah absolutely so they
so that comes with you know the boost of
confidence it actually comes with a
little every deal is different I don't
know how much legally I can say about
this stuff but they they promise you so
there's four models that get kicked
around right this will give you good
I'll take so like the Apple arcade model
what might have hurt its you get up you
get a promised amount of money mmm-hmm
your game which I guess is based on some
economists inside of Apple decides how
much they think your money will make and
then room for nears it in to look like a
lump sum okay and then off Apple is also
rumored to have a kind of a trickle pay
more than hours you pay it play the game
oh
whether that's true or not I don't know
any insight i from what I promote
experience with Xbox they promise you a
lump sum of money
mmm-hmm on release of the game guys we
can also sell the game on their their
standard Xbox store but if you're on as
you get you get it for free so for us it
allowed us to no matter I don't think
unless you're one of these really really
pure artist that's willing to like live
on the streets for their art hey need to
make money yeah it may be a debut
secured
exactly right when Xbox says hey we're
gonna give you this lump sum of money it
allowed us there and I you never have a
conversation anymore about like well
will that be attractive to players from
a financial perspective like actually
the health bar thing is one thing right
will that be too polarizing to people
right turn so many people that they
won't buy the game right but when Xbox
give you that back and you're like no
we're we're gonna do this not just to be
reckless but because we believe in it
artistically and
gives you the confidence that little
boost of confidence like make those kind
of decisions and also it like as King
was saying like this thought that like
people are gonna be able to come to game
pass and then try out the game with zero
or event read like that's an amazing yes
beeper for you get people that went into
game pass for gears and they still got
it in there and they look at on this
video what's this new game and they try
it out sharing that real estate on the
UI you know again with these other
bigger games or Triple A or get you know
I'm saying like there's value to that
and I'm glad you said what you said
because there's there's a lot of
misconception right now about game pass
and and in a lot of people like oh it's
it's hurting the developers you know say
I'm glad you said what you said because
people think that like it's some giving
away if you know of a game and it's not
it's it's it for you based on what
you're saying obviously there is a
financial responsibility that is
promised to you upon release and
obviously you know having this game that
might not have been seen I mean we know
your multiplayer right we know your own
ps4 we know your switch and I'm Steeve
me all that stuff but again it's
fighting for real estate on all those
classes and the good thing is you know
just cuz you're on game pass doesn't
mean that you know I have my friend John
that has a Playstation come over and he
sees me playing you're gay but he only
got a PlayStation or PC so now he gotta
go home and buy it no but what what I
like the most is the fact that you know
because there's a lot of controversy as
well cut me a little saying about gaming
pass in general and the fact that you
said no the bag is there that gave me
security brother that that in itself
allows the decision making going forward
a little bit more easier facts and then
you know because I'm pretty sure I I do
this every week and I'm pretty sure I'm
not the only person I do that does this
I pick one game on the new releases that
I'm gonna check out and I'm gonna report
about it good better and different but
something I'm curious about that I don't
have because we were in an economic
times where hard earned cash is not easy
to come by
Oh
you know you you're balancing multiple
things or let's say this holiday season
you don't have enough money for gifts or
whatever you choosing to do but in your
game is gonna have to take a backseat
and you're waiting for your income tax
come up I said you know that's the fun
bucks you know you able to purchase two
or three games are you looking for
holiday specials like Black Friday or
something like that this game past
alleviates that stress going forward
because you're able to try things
normally financially you aren't viable
and able to do right and I'm so happy
that it went it was like game pass I
said it's in there more people will get
a chance to see and talk about your game
facts fast and this is not available if
this program is not in place right so
just for clarity because again there's a
lot of misconceptions lowest even like a
lot of people really feel like I
shouldn't say a lot but a lot of
uninformed people you know I'm making
assumptions that game pass is hurting
you guys right that that there's no way
that this can help the developers and
assembly line of non quality games being
forced out but right so so for the
record can you say that that game pad is
helping unto the end 100% I mean under
the Sarah and I would be in a different
mental state and and kind of planning
differently if game Pass wasn't around
you know I think that there's definitely
always misconception I think the fear I
was actually on a panel at egx talking
about this exact topic talking about mmm
description based services and art is it
gonna you know wreck games quote-unquote
mm-hmm fit for the moment it's excellent
I don't want to put it you know a downer
on there unfortunately you know it could
go I don't think it will but it could go
the way if like you know iTunes and and
kind of you know what Spotify has done
to music industry which you know when
when someone releases and I don't know
much but my understanding it if you
release an album as an artist you get
you know micro extends mm-hmm for every
time that the song is played on
something like Spotify and so that is a
lot of kind of independent artists
making money right turn to the Netflix
model which is
that Netflix goes out and curates you
know directors and creators that that
are doing interesting things and brings
them into the Netflix full words before
you know they would have had to go the
old kind of Hollywood route which is
like get what big studios to like make a
movie but entirely on their own so I
think if if and it seems to be that if
next box and these other you know
subscription services Apple arcade main
in kind of the the Netflix route right
then we'll be okay and I think we the
reason I feel like we will be okay is
that creativity is coming that you is
hard still to bottle up and right but
look for mmm-hmm
both in terms of like what other
creatives thinks is interesting but also
fans people that got the consume content
first to create it and so you kind of
are left with having to go with the
Netflix model I think for games because
it's so hard to predict what the next
big hit would be nice yes one of my
favorite of all time and most big
inspiration Ria's Dark Souls nice which
Dark Souls one came out you know Demon
Souls as well like that really bucked
the trend of like where Chris play games
were going right and everyone like no
one's gonna play a game that is is
really obtuse that doesn't hold your
hand and I don't you know I think
without you know curating a catalogue
the taste having risks of the you are
you gonna lose love you know a point
completely it kind of like well in all
its itself out so I think it's an
excellent thing for mmm-hmm games
definitely is developers for Sarah and I
it's been using the Xbox guys are just
fantastic to work with they they helped
both financially but also with you know
in terms of marketing and stuff like
that but getting up ages exposure you
know you sarin I could never get on her
own so yeah it's really been amazing I
can't say enough good things the magic
moment that's what I call it man like I
said the little guy you know he's got
he's got his shine and you may make some
valid points because again you know the
way game design is going and the way
these games are getting more expensive
it's harder and harder for foot I feel
for publishers to take risks with these
games you know sometimes you know people
kind of fall in those lines of you know
if this is working this is the new trend
wherever is lewder shooter whether it's
battle royal whatever it is right so
like you said sometimes these smaller up
to games they may look at you guys like
hey that's a risk but then you look at a
service like a game past whatever and
you know it's in this catalog right this
hole here at a catalog so again you may
have the guy who's coming in there just
specifically for the battle royal for
the FPS for the looter shooter and it's
like oh what's this what's this unto the
end thing and because I'm subscribed
it's like it's free so to speak right so
it's like oh all right and you know
you're sharing real estate with these
other bigger giant games and it's like
yo look at this game and then all of a
sudden now more people discover it more
people discover it as opposed to it not
being in a service like that yeah I
think I think there is advantages to
that man and I get I just wanted to
salute you guys because again I know how
I felt when I saw you guys all that bad
stage and I said again even if it was
two seconds I was the loudest person in
the Microsoft theater it Cali de Velde
you're like yeah I could try to pull
that I don't know man I don't know why
he's active
I was like that's my guy I like there we
go it did have a look around make sure
no one's looking at it yeah I was
definitely out of control I was I was I
was yelling I was a little ridiculous
but I just say like it was because you
we spoke out there and you like this is
what I couldn't tell you you're like oh
that's loot to turd man this is really
cool love what I'm here from that and
obviously last question in reference to
unto in far as you know the famous my
motto saying you know game finish game
you know we don't want it to be rushed
you know say do you want it so you know
what as we're where we are now with
development and kind of like where you
your ETA as far as release what you're
thinking about yeah we think summertime
it seems realistic there and I we had a
really good egx
what's that summer of arcade part yeah
yeah we uh we had a really good ejects
that was our first time showing it
publicly we had a lot of people play it
feedback was really strong from that so
we don't feel like we have a lot of
things to adjust and to and I think when
you're making a game sometimes you have
to pivot and that can slow down
development so now it's just about
finishing things you know we have alpha
major all the systems are done all the
mechanics are built out
it should bring up the art to the kind
of the level of quality that we want
mm-hmm
summer is is realistic a little bit will
depend on basically we have our
publisher will take the game which we
will build for PC in unity right it will
do a port for the different platforms
like quick and PlayStation right Spock
should be pretty easy to do
yes which is harder which is harder
because you know just from a technical
perspective
there will be no slander and so much
gank it's coming for y'all can you do me
a favor essence hardware slang tell them
that it's coming to one of the balls of
vibrant platforms Lord even though the
switch side of things even just to let
you know we just rubbing a kognito and
little or salvor in the wrong way right
now because they are heavy switch fans
we are all switched and we all have
switches but we just like basically we
get the eluvian socket port shamed
anytime right right tire is both our
fight comes in switch it is any type of
graphical fidelity issues we always get
clowned but continue it'll require some
extra work you gotta we gotta hold this
the best this is
he says they love claymation you have to
do you might have to cut the real-estate
the sixteen by nine side-by-sides come
out will hold but I guess where I'm
going to be playing in my game pastor
that is it is definitely more attractive
for me and gay but like I said for
people who don't have Xbox just a fact
of law making it available for
multi-platform the PlayStation nation
the switch game awesome they can have
taken lease you know have to get to it
so um shot the boss move switch
development needs some tender let me get
shut up for me anyway moving look final
question that we ask all our guests oh
here we go this is the one the only I
need from lost even his top video games
or franchises of all time top five cool
so I saw your other pocket so I knew
this was coming in two ways one like
there's games I like for nostalgia and
then there's games that are kind of
current so like I don't know useful to
kind of break it across that but okay in
terms of like games that really impacted
me they're kind of nostalgic Lee a game
called zillion I don't know if you guys
yes absolute is greatness doing what I
think I actually to as well I'd know if
you guys were played zillion too but
there's like a BS mean there I remember
like I was playing across the street
were there and my brother we're all like
I was I was trying to clear it
I actually kicked them out of the room
it was so lessened like it that day and
then like call them back in when I like
beat that game but it's one I think I
mean I get no I kind of understand like
the the aunt Sega's answer for like on
metroid aghanim as the thing that made
gillian one brilliant was that little
puzzle system like that that was like a
memory game at that time bina like a
kind of a side-scroller kind of action
game I thought was I thought like the
little characters were cool again the
actually game design wise did some
brilliant things like they would tease
you with like seeing like kind of the
the Carbonite version of like champ or
Apple yeah yeah go around the world
together
yeah exactly super cool I thought I said
oh that came from time to time like on
emulators and stuff so I remembered a
song right now oh yeah my dad bought
that game for me and my brother he went
to like a computer store mm-hmm and he
brought it home because he thought it
looked cool yes and then he played it
and again I made it extra special to
like kind of having in because he's not
into games and you know so having him
like it that kind of made like I would
so like a less nostalgic one the more
like a Curt one I have to throw like
Dark Souls in there really kind of like
for me I guess it that along with kind
of the resurgence of indie games like
you know kind of in the movie kind of
thing made it seem like hey I could make
a game you know like some of the things
I like about games still I still like
people and I could go make and make a
game and maybe that's weird and you're
looking like a Dark Souls because it's
such a massive game but it it kind of
did things that I really appreciated
about games like the no handhold alan
geing game and and it kind of made me
yeah it kind of revitalized my my
passion for game so that's definitely in
there another game yeah another game I
really loved was a faster-than-light I
don't know if you guys play down it all
begin it's what I liked about it was it
it's a roguelike your management Manning
ship you have a crew and you come across
these battles and the battles kind of
happen in real time but you can pause
them and you really it's about building
up and managing your crew and things
like that and hitting them to the side
good things but the thing I loved about
that game is that one it I told a story
through these moments like you're moving
through this gal
see and you're kind of piecing these
story elements and it's kind of feeding
you that incrementally and every time
you play it's almost like a different
story I'm looking at it right now
it's not there's no hand-holding at all
like the first time your [ __ ] catches on
fire and everything fall apart it
explodes but then you kind of learn a
little bit from that so the next time it
happens you figure out there's like a
way to deal with it so there's all these
like little emergent things you can do
to deal with guys aboard your ship like
fire like you know running out of
shields and so yep that's really great
sense of accomplishment as you like go
through through the game the thing has
got a 5 out of 5 from fangame an 89% on
PC game and 10 out of 10 on Steam yeah
brilliant game into the breach I know if
you guys have played I'd yeah yes yeah a
few subset games and the compulsive burn
poetry music a roguelike it's it looks
phenomenal yeah it's got a steep
learning curve I found it but once you
get into it it's I think it's very very
well designed so it's definitely up
there for me I'm a huge Elda fan so like
for me a Link to the Past really stand
behind the beginning of that game we're
like the father tells you to stay at
home yeah and it's entirely off on you
to leave mm-hmm I I just like like
masterful game design because it makes
me as the player like fully in control
of my destiny and I have to break
through that barrier mm-hmm I think
that's like one of my all-time favorite
games what's funny is uh that kind of
carried over throughout the generations
because yes in certain games like far
cry 4 he tells you to stay in that room
while he goes and get your mother's
ashes that if you stay there he
literally breathing your mother's ashes
in the game adjoining the realm we do
appreciate you brother and we have a ton
of stuff coming through some videos will
be up this week for all members of the
realm that hit that joint button those
videos will only be afforded to you
guys use those emojis man we got some
funny things going on man
so that's what sister okay so what was
the final one you said I have a long
list of games I'm gonna throw one out
there's probably maybe controversial but
so I think below the game like a P I
know if you guys play it yeah I I think
that to me like Miyamoto had this idea
he always talks like smoother I usually
he quit he rage quit though it's a it's
a very demanding game but the the thing
I think it the reason I love it is i
think one they took a hell of a lot of
risks and I have to applaud like an
indie developer to do for doing that
even though Cappy has had success with
sword and sorcery and some but none
mm-hmm I think they took a lot of risk
so I applaud that but for me Miyamoto
had this vision with Zelda of like he
would talk about he'd go into these
caves and in the forest as a kid and and
he would explore those and and that
sense of like not knowing whether to go
left or right or feeling alone and kind
of overwhelmed I think below did a
better job of that for me than any other
game where it really throws you like a
lone adventure on and I let you have to
figure out how to survive yes
you know weapons to use what what what
how enemies work how did how to assemble
like Lantern like it is no really
doubled your hand at all
and it's definitely not a perfect game I
I think they did make some mistakes
design-wise but for me to feel that
experience they were able to capture is
I don't know if you guys have played
throughout but there's moments near the
end where you're fighting this one
creature and it is like some of the most
intense demanding game my hands are like
sweating and that's pretty rare to keep
great in the game and although it's
definitely very punishing yes the fear
of loss when you die that was really a
magical experience and just you know
it's why I love games work for those
experiences you can't get anywhere you
can't get that in the movie you can't
get that in the book like that's really
a game
experience absolutely tremendous
top-five yeah got a chance to go behind
the scenes with Cappy closed-door but
right before release maybe uh yeah I
mean PAX last year and I definitely saw
was like wow this thing looks
challenging but it I'll of it exactly
you can share some similarities that in
terms I've felt like in terms of Omni on
so you don't say it definitely yeah and
I think that kind of organically but I
think that what they realized and Sarah
died realizes that everyone most for
most part is scared of the dark
yes you know in some way we know you're
there Tara and I were in Hawaii and we
were going through this lava - I don't
have you've ever been in your pure
darkness but we're going through this
life there's kind of the tour area where
there's lighting and then there's like
this area they have like it's guarded
off they're like go in if you want but
this is the end of the desert where the
King goes we have these flashlights
you're going through and it's amazing
how crappy flashlights are in pure dark
light like there you go anywhere and
they actually make everything scarier
the box store flashlights buy you good
flashlights the Kohen so that feeling of
like darkness and being alone is
something we definitely like latched
onto and I think blow does a really good
job of that I also feel a little
defensive because I think Chris
Petrovsky and the Cappy team took a huge
number of risks and a lot of the
feedback guys on steam forums were like
this game is poorly designed these guys
don't respect me and I thought the exact
top so I think these guys like poured
their heart and soul into this game from
a design effective in a field
perspective and I just thought shame
that people hated on it so much I did I
didn't think it was just I thought it
should really be celebrated as a bold
empted doing something different it was
kind of you know that top-down kind of
Zelda kind of feels oh yeah right to go
I can say this no I saw the game I was
intrigued by the game but what allowed
me to actually touch and play the game
and download a date-date was the fact
that it was in game past so annotations
for me and a trepidation and purchase
because I was able to partake you know
without the fear of loss and when I
played the game I said wow this is
something I needed my stable and I see
it
leaving game passing now and it should
be leaving I think at the end of this
month but I'm going to you know purchase
a game because that's one of the games
that I want as uh you know one of my
staples of games that you show like your
son or your daughter or whatever like
this is what a real heart serious game
that doesn't hold your hands is about
absolutely love you already like that is
like in the bush without and that was
definitely a classic band again salute
Stephen coming through weight on to the
end news
hopefully 2020 summer hopefully okay and
we want everyone to enjoy it and you
know but we do want to make it you know
something we're very proud of so twenty
Twenty twenty summer seems very very
doable so sounds good this gave me a
student really appreciate it's been a
really fun time hopefully we can do it
again absolutely Bay like I said if you
got to go we know it we got a little bit
more show but if you got it want to hang
out you can add more to so it's up
totally up to you I got it I got it just
can I take a quick break no wait we will
could do running our mouths you come
right back
the last week's poll results are in and
the people have spoken to the question
with the majority of the major software
releases now having shipped in 2019 what
is your current choice for Game of the
Year the winner of a very divisive
four-way ILP poll at 44% is dears five
group coveted at second place at 23% was
Bibi mood at doe company that a razor
close third place it's tough to do raise
your close and in sadly in last place
bundle you gotta get Sarah Stephen back
on the podcast just after until of
course of course yes we would definitely
get the lower back so that was the pole
resorts Lord sovereign what are you
feeling about this man thinks akiro
should be one thank you very much though
guys yeah Eva just doesn't get picked
all the time somebody's ten is somebody
six guaranteed that's and that is my
rage against this machine it is forcing
these fools to run out their bodies I
gotta be in the moment let me buy this
again no man go dig in the Benz and go
get last year's game of the year that
you didn't even play yet you're just
trying to be current I don't know I
don't even see my backlog as a backlog
anymore it's just my collection that's
all the end of the show so we gonna
start off real quick with a hot off the
presses leakage might be happening
so shout out to Twitter user PS Erebus
who has some history of leaking things
on the PlayStation Society actually
correctly leaked the initial take that
man correct the official date the gotcha
they got jail he was right before they
delayed he was right so shout-out to PS
Erebus and pretty much the the leak the
rumor is that a PlayStation 5 could
released November you know saying what a
price of $4.99 in the u.s. the
speculative date is November 20th so
that is again this is leaked rumor
nothing confirmed we just gonna talk
about it's hot off the press so I'm
gonna bring this to the Lord's you know
what do we think about this I'm a sort
of Lord addict first man like what do
you think about if this is true
PlayStation 5 so I'm gonna give Captain
Obvious an award man yeah November Oh
like that's not a huge stretch I've been
posted in a while what can I put up huge
pocket watches out here I would say all
those if he would have said like March
the 20th okay you know he might know
something
you're things like those serenade that's
like me saying Call of Duty's come out
November guess what Lord that King David
mm-hmm guess what Call of Duty's coming
up November the 10th it came out
November last year and the year before
that and the year before that I said a
push to remember they were I think was
the main use clack so we got that Lord
Steve I see he has returned the again
some some leakage going on with
Playstation 5 release date or possibly
being
November 20 it's 500 out of price point
you know what do you think do you think
this could be accurate with this it's
kind of a ballpark or you think this
might be way off you know I don't know
it drought it's like I
I when you're when I'm working on our
game I like have such a backlog of video
games like in terms of like things I got
to play I'm Lu pin terms of like
consoles and stuff like that if you told
me it came up every you know I bribe you
like yep okay great PC master race
I think I I attached the interesting for
like Sarah died releasing next year and
you know there's rumors like the next
Xbox console will come out no it's
interesting when a new console comes out
like you know it's a lot of hype and
there's you know of course the
excitement around it you know what will
happen you know like it selfishly what
will happen with the ps4 games tick you
know the one game controversy but you
know they got a system to play your game
[Laughter]
for $4.99 you swipe that card is it in
the ground Phyllis might be in the realm
of possibility Lord Steve I mean it's
you know for me I but I I'm not nearly
as up-to-date as you guys are over these
things so it's it's step possible I mean
first route so need to go early like
that earlier the Xbox I guess I guess
it's it's possible that they they
definitely don't want to do it at the
same time as right Microsoft so they
kind of got to make a decision
business-wise do we want to delay until
after you know box comes out which
wouldn't put it till November they want
to kind of get out ahead of it for
Christmas beats and it kind of you know
trying to try to beat them good fight
though I guess not yep this cocky is
sewn you getting here like that wouldn't
be surprised they put out the same day
Xbox off advance so what you think this
I mean I think I got exciting about the
timeframe and the price the most safety
is super safe I don't
I don't think they can't get they can't
get away with 399 for this console it's
just too much in both of these consoles
I don't I don't think so
um what's interesting is the date right
because 20th when you look at lat last a
console launch they launched on the 15th
I believe it was yeah and the Xbox
launched on the 22nd a week later yes by
this launching on the 20th I doubt very
much Xbox would launch the week of
Thanksgiving for that app puts Xbox
probably launching before if this
release date is correct added so I mean
a curveball in March in October they
could even do that they could you know I
think especially with Sony going at the
end of November you know the people
might change up there's a history there
wasn't a history and releasing in March
and so I think it could be said that you
know after the launch at Xbox one they
can break tradition and go go left and
start start a new tradition lots of the
same month does that come out to stitch
with the final a super chat how does a
poop throwing and walking simulator
managed to be in the game of the I have
food coming to me because I have to be
plenty energized for that topic yes so
kitty so I will say again November 22nd
is a big date for Xbox usually but that
if this date is true that would put
Xboxes launch of a if they continue that
22nd try that one the following Monday
which is like I said the week of
Thanksgiving right I don't know that it
makes a lot of sense so if this is true
I see Xbox launching a week before gosh
and plus they're gonna want a long way
before Thanksgiving because they're
gonna want to properly market before
Black Friday
go listen
what y'all understand is your man's is
acting out of character living it
because the new people on deck don't
know how it really goes so you say
they're bending the knee know what it is
is they showing me slip you see under
the skirt they're not supposed to be
talking like this usually the people
that are Lincoln is Microsoft but see
this is what happens when a boss is in
place a boss is in place and he know
their cadence now he told you the
cadence when you saw X own team
the cadence was we're going to keep
showing you every show you're going to
get bangers as we go forward you're
going to get new games going forward
they're pushing idea Xbox they're pushed
in game past they're pushing their
service and that system is coming next
year they're not to tell you when the
system is coming you're not gonna find
out in a leak you're not gonna find out
in this and y'all leaking all over the
place this I'm buried this is very
troublesome now in the troubles of stage
listen they try a lot that is true that
is all right so look is this our new
problem of journalism that's not let's
not discredit him because he's been
right so you can't say that you know
some random do when he's been right so
nobody it's not like his words hasn't
been spoken it hasn't been felt right
all right so he came out with the arm
the proper date for us too and it got
moved you know so yes for you said same
guy leak scarlet $5.00 leak scarlet a
$500 I don't think it stuff is factual
I don't think it's factual because I
also believe that this leak was
encouraged okay because I see the
PlayStation fan base like see told you
was not going to be 600 they feel
comfortable with the 500 that's nice you
feel comfortable with the 500 jobs
complaining when the X came out and was
500 rates did well they did fantastic
listen we're gonna pay a premium price
for these new systems going forward
that's nothing new that's something that
we understand and we also know it's
gonna come in a fall so stop acting like
you guys think this is some new stuff
attic is onto something when he's
telling you there Captain Obvious needs
an award this is stuff that doesn't need
to be safe but for some reason it's
being leaked from these individuals now
y'all might try to keep the same energy
because if Nintendo orders leaking
something y'all be like oh something's
wrong with Nintendo Microsoft is always
every show they leak not one leak came
out as in the past they've had and we
would spoil it got spoiled for us going
forward this EXO there was not a drop of
spoilage and I believe Langley I believe
going forward then from the top down
when you see uniformity you see somebody
on your team
that means the personal gain is not
necessary to leak out information
because they're moving as one in the
unit it looks like your unit is not
moving together and you got guys moving
out of factions all over the place
unified mine wins you guys do not look
unified and this in this situation is
getting very spooky and I want to know
when the red flags is gonna start going
up from ok what do you guys think of the
potential that GT you can't raise mo 7
is a launch game can I get some in the
bushes for Gran Turismo 7 I get some in
the bushes launching window Gran Turismo
see will will see that the Dow jump in
real quick football yeah I mean look I
it is a little bit of a Captain Obvious
month kind of a deal but you know
specific date we'll see five hundred
seems about on point they probably take
the the hit on hardware this thing seems
to be a be straight racing we know what
the Zen process said we see the
architecture that supposed to be rooming
in this thing SSDs and all type of stuff
so you know this is definitely premium
architecture seems on point I guess the
question for me will be how does
Scarlett County react we've heard you
know they are in kind of similar
architectures but at the same time
there's some suppose it's secret sauce
that AMD and Microsoft was working with
and then um the other thing comes down
to you know besides that the rumor of
the lockhart because we did hear that
there was an initial to double skew
approach that breaks off my lip with the
anaconda and the lock are so it will be
interesting if they come back them and
say okay hey we have our premium console
at five hundred to match but that it's
like a lower entry point we have a three
hundred or whatever price point lower to
get people in the ecosystem and then
maybe you know i don't know if they
bundling gamepad we got a photo super
chat from brat why spend five hundred
and in fear product with lower frame
rate muddy texture home laura graphical
settings pc master a last time I check
you you wouldn't get to play a game of
the Year last year you wouldn't get to
play runner-up last year when it came
out you didn't get to play a lot of
games that well you don't get a play got
a war there's amazing stuff that's all
PC pisspot acted like oh hold on Brad go
update your drivers Christopher Hart
I know I know Sonny's gonna kill it but
see unlike most day and date I'm buying
three of them cuz I got three different
televisions I'm buying three three boxes
so if this doesn't matter to me this is
I don't care premium talk what you have
to understand is I'm going to have it
all I'm not limited in myself I don't
care who wins
making the most games at the end of the
day is gonna be interested I'm very
curious about Microsoft response to this
stuff you know saying so that's what we
got on the leak for picked by 65 but we
gonna move on to the main event
Lord addict man these game awards are
causing a lot of controversy there's a
lot of my topic technically it is a
shared topic a shared topic so I mean
I'll start off you know just will set it
up right so pretty much obviously the
game always have come and go but you're
just so everyone in the chat knows this
is the main event this is a real man
this is the main event this is what
they're the round wanted to see what the
Lord's felt and it's very very
conflicting very polarizing comments
Twitter is a battlefield right now we
have the game of the Year nominations
that were announced by Geoff Keighley
and obviously we saw a lot of them on
believe it was control death stranding
Sakura and both of you forgetting off
top now super smash super smash has been
outerworld in the outer worlds correct
so you know pro being in there wants me
to rip my eyeballs yeah there was some
omissions that had people upset there
was no gears 5 located there as well as
Jedi fallen order which kind of missed
the cut and apparently you know
according to the rules November 15th was
the cutoff date so technically it made
it but then there was a statement issued
by the game award stating hey you know
arm
they made an internal decision that they
didn't have enough time to review the
game so it that's trying to keep on the
we will get to that but up so look we're
gonna bring it to the realm obviously
the point of contention for a lot of
gamers not all but a lot is def training
and the amount of nominations it reseda
believe received nine and the supposed
relationship or conflict of interest
that some people are pointing with with
Geoff Keighley
you know and
Dale kijima and things of that nature so
let's start it off I'm gonna actually
start with soft cuz I don't wanna get
his perspective and I think we've talked
too much um what is your feeling on this
whole thing do you feel it's justified
that people have concerns about this and
um just in general like where are you at
with the outrage or a lack of outrage do
you feel that he's following the
protocol because he hasn't voted on the
nomination himself he actually came out
with statement say hey I don't vote on
these things you know I'm saying we have
an advisory board so we're yeah so I
mean I think overall in general all of
these these awards mean nothin the super
subjective everybody has their different
awards or whatever so in general this is
not a big deal but at the same time
Keeley's awards are the ones that are
always front and center at the end of
every year those are the ones that sort
of they stand out more than anybody else
is I know individual outlets have their
awards but these stand out because they
make a big presentation out of it and
and also people watch them for new
announcements right so it's a big deal
and the fact that he they've been
transparent about the fact that he does
not vote on this they haven't they have
sort of a committee that they baked with
other heads of development houses that
vote on this um but at the same time
it's like it can't be underscored the
flag right this game just came out and
it's got nominated for all of these
awards and he's his obvious closeness
with kojima and and the fact that this
event is associated solely with kili
like oh man you talk about the Oscars we
talk about Emmys whatever the case may
be
this oh this is never associated with
one person optics around Keeley being
the centerpiece of these awards all the
time Oh braaap coming at you right he
said fire on a super chat he said -
stranded nomination was a perfect call
no quid pro quo he said that aid was
released he said Cagiva doesn't even
know jeff fake new Saab you got it
if you hope to see more yes we will hope
to see more from develop and hopefully
get lost
[Music]
that was brilliant just you know he just
it's just a uh what you would call it uh
what do you call Keeley in a way has
sort of again unfairly unfairly its his
sort of blow waiting around Kojima and
how he was treated when he got you know
bumped from Konami and stuff like that
right
you just make people sort of question
motivations and whether again behind the
scenes he has nothing to do with it the
optics don't look good regardless to
what it is don't look good and like I
said the big thing is the fact that
these awards are associated with keenly
no one else mmm
nobody else they just aren't they never
have been in the face well he's all host
he's the founder he's the host and
producer of the show exactly so with
this man getting this many awards for a
game that if you if the game came out
and it was universally praised
universally praised i god of ward
universally praised right I don't
universally pray that impress it I said
[Laughter]
this divisive period it was revised
harsh the board this it just kind of
doesn't make I think is the sympathy
vote sovereign I'm sorry if people don't
understand all the things that go on
with this man he did not like our icons
to be besmirched okay I made joke a lot
about this game but he was not treated
fairly at the end he did not get his
gold watch he was denied access to shows
because they wanted to be petty with
this man and he gave his hard earned
listen we have a developer on right now
and he just told you the trials and
tribulations that he had to go through
to get his game out okay so at no point
time will we diminish the efforts of any
developer making a game and being
treated unfairly in their work
environment
so yeah the outcry for everybody else to
rally behind this man and to stand up
for this man I don't care about the game
itself I think I think a lot of
denominations is based off of the
sympathy vote and how this man was treat
any any gold track and it goes back to
that thing where if anybody else but
Kojima mind you I don't think anybody
else but Kojima makes this game right
right right but removing him from the
equation this exact game comes out from
someone else let me let me ask you this
shout-out to first of all for Brandon
Bryce - phylla - super chat thank you
Lord for having great shows thank you
brother for the super champion I love
you get this extra no you got two
dollars super champion snitch this is
the Kojima Awards oh my gosh he got
Butch's emojis shouted his new emojis
for put them in the bushes but here's
the thing like I want to ask - I mean to
solve and Kings point as far as you get
you guys are playing on this sympathy
thing right so my question is do you
feel because of what happened with the
Konami situation and we do know Geoff
Keighley that year stop by McKee for
suppling and separate the war because
Kojima was unable to sure do we feel
because he kind of galvanized the
community to make us aware of what
happened and why Kojima couldn't accept
it that it kind of his influence kind of
created a sympathetic figure as far as
what is happen do you feel that that is
him doing that created influence is the
question I think it did immediately in
that moment but then since then I mean
the man dream is doing well we don't
have to worry right because his mental
state has to be called manga artists in
their form in their craft and their
painting is going to come out in their
in their craft oh this game is super
self indulgent this is his this is he's
telling a lot about his feelings and
he's been through in this game
absolutely wonderful sighs but see also
this Geoff Keighley being his friend if
your friend and anybody on his panel can
rally to the your friend yes yes oh yeah
is he in a bad position that this is a
his award show and again he's made a
stance on his last award show that his
friend could not be the washoe to pick
up his stuff he brought a light to it
right so of course when the game does
finally come out a highly anticipated
game and it does get all his sympathy
votes and these nominations and stuff
going forward people are rightly gonna
look at the individual is in charge his
name is on the bill his name in lights
alright what about King let's say he
when he came out with the statement he
said look I don't vote I don't vote so
is not a sympathy like I don't he's
basically saying what is Twitter he's
literally responding there people
directly on Twitter so would you say
that right look at which in review tech
right and I got a chance to watch this
video 5 this this is a little bit more
deeper Venice Geoff Keighley
this goes into what is the group name is
for firm it's another Japanese yes yet
firm editor is in the game yes the game
and for and they got they got perfect
for which they very rarely get any game
that that man has been associated in has
got a perfect score yes so this leads
more into why we question that man and
his nomination that he has it's he's on
the board right so they have a vote he's
in the game he gave the game a perfect
score that he is in this is not the
first game that he has also been
involved in that was a snake eater in
another game a Japanese only game and
they have gotten perfect scores and so
if you want to look at the corruption
the corruption has led to this one
individual Geoff Keighley does not
actually have a vote but this individual
or do I let me get you on you but you
gave breath cuz I got you always have to
get Brad you gotta get read because I
gotta John I like a job to be a victim
bar guys feeling that super chair you
can get Brad yeah you give
we're all ignoring the real question is
BiBi old enough to vote at the TV salute
look so brat if you want to let you want
to get Tsavo King you want to get
perhaps of a chat well you got to say
alright so you know so if there's any
blonde in the corner rambro okay it's
not to provide us with chat if the
sympathy thing was true Metal Gear Solid
5 would have won Game of the Year it did
it along the panel has played the game
let me let me address that let me
address that before Saul shuts you down
all right Metal Gear saw a so how does
that make any sense we're gonna give the
company that did that to that man hold
on now before we got lost even Rock I
gotta be very careful
get him in trouble but he's right now to
comment if he chooses you know all this
situation train carefully make sure you
if you feel uncomfortable you know you
can just reduce yourself as well we give
you the option and we don't want to not
include you but we also want to give the
option no I think it is a sensitive
topic definitely as a developer too but
I will say that I think some of the
sympathy thing resonates but it might be
slightly more that gaming needs Kojima
like you know being I think needs people
to be able to hold up as kind of the
Spielberg's and Lukas's of the art form
yes because I think they help give it
give it
validity and move it I think gaming is
still you know I think all of us here
understand gaming as a you know a high
form of art and creativity but the world
at large may not see it exactly in that
way yes and I think without guys like
Kojima or Miyamoto or whatever are
Miyazaki you don't it's harder to
establish gaming you know at the highest
activity and I think you have to protect
these guys to a degree yes I have not
played des training I've seen a lot of
it I think it has a ton of very
interesting ideas the gameplay I always
like to look at games and say okay if
you made this in like black and white
one bit you know visual format but it'd
still be a good game right you know I'm
not sure that
would be yeah so that's hard to say but
right uh I think some of the sympathy
may also be about kind of maintaining
the integrity of you know kind of the
the the highest you know people in the
game injury I do want to point out
something real quick you know bright cue
Sade
advisory board this advisory board that
so I wouldn't look up this list mm-hmm
briefly go over this list shall we we
have the activision president i'm not
saying their names you could look their
names up yeah we had the AMD CEO mm-hmm
we have the cheap studio officer for EA
we have the Google Phil Harrison no no
we don't need to go too much to him then
we have uh
Kojima right then we have Phil Spencer
it then Doug boughs are the president of
Nintendo I don't even know what this one
is then we have rock games Sony
Entertainment
Val right so it's from that list I said
does this sound like Kojima deserve why
is he even on the advisory well that's
it that's another question I mean if you
look at it like you have the president
of companies you have this like
literally the the founders of the
industry pretty much but I'm saying is
he he looks at like he looks like he
shouldn't be the really the red hair we
go yeah we go from Bill Spence he's over
between those winter and Phil Harris
above him is the CEO of AMD that makes
all the hardware Veloz below him is rock
star to the side of him his dog Bowser
then you gotta Jima isn't kijima though
one of the pillars in our community like
are you talking about this guy
and I'm talking about on a purely game
level right okay because somebody
frauded me out on Twitter yeah and I had
to explain to him why I didn't purchase
the game oh yeah I was gonna buy the
game when I know that you can roll the
baby around in his own like that I was
definitely gonna body game I mean off of
the strangeness of that alone you say
that all I was saying is that of all the
people on here it feels like some people
was put on here because of their
positions and he was put on there
because of his relations and was a
little in fashion what's what's wrong
with that because a lot of people get
java in the industry in places for
people that they know and not watching
no just enforces that you know that
people that he's oh he's literally in
here with the biggest people in the
industry he oh he owns a studio everyone
owns a studio like this would not be an
issue if this game wasn't an issue you
understand because he was on the board
before but nobody cared then but now
it's an issue because he's in Michael
Jackson status right now let let the man
breathe let them breathe shout the neil
mental with the follower Chad -
stranding is a good game it's not great
quit Donald trumping over here how would
you assume gay more I please get the NYT
music super chat please so what I'm
gonna use anything but I'm gonna use
Christopher Hart since Christopher Hart
out here captain Phil Spencer is the
executive vice president of the game
Awards don't fraud yourselves P people
and King listen no it's not a color but
I'm New York and MIT music didn't put
anything so I'm just gonna be somebody
random from the chat and I'm making sure
that I highlight Christopher for this
nobodies floating anybody in here
nobody's Katherine on this game except
for yourself what we're explaining is
the fundamental corruption that we see
right here in front of our eyes now I'm
not saying Geoff Keighley is the
corrupted of entity here I'm looking
more at
for Mitchell to be honest with you
because that level of corruption has has
reared its head where he is in in-game
raps on Kotaku has written
Kotaku has written an article saying do
not trust for Mitchell scores okay yo
all right so Bret fire on a super Chet
the advisory board does not fall on
winners and they do not nominate we do
Jeff we're not vote and doesn't nominate
we're not talking about the advisory
board voting did that ever come out of
my mouth no it did it I never said they
voted I said from a standpoint of
looking at that advisory boat kijima is
the odd man out because he doesn't look
like he just you have bill Spencer
obviously he deserves to be explained to
me besides friendship why he's on their
breath it's just the fact that it really
stinks and you know we're in a community
where we are more soulful where the
finger tips the information is at our
fingertips at the moment now so we can
look up stuff we can see stuff we can
bet are fact check things so a lot of
the corruption that was going along
before when people weren't self-aware
and they weren't passing this
information on was going under you know
the table not anymore
so this should be highlighted it should
be talked about it should be a talking
point do I care about award shows no I
don't because a lot of the games that I
love will never be nominated you know
you see games like the last station like
I told you guys to go play I will push
it forward a hundred times go play this
game and this game won't be nominated
which top three tier games please get
your visa Jonathan B with the $5 super
chat Martin Luther Kojima jr. wonder
rush not able to play games and peace do
to discourage addicts show me on the
doll where Cagiva touched you yo they
going
another thing that we haven't touched
the puzzle mental to why these awards
are always gonna sort of be divisive and
it's always gonna be an issue is and
it's neither of fully it's not an award
show that's fully voted on by industry
people while fully voted on by fans only
10% of the vote comes from fans they
need to figure out what this you know
what I would say if you want to
quote-unquote legitimize it yeah either
do one of the other make it fully
industry or fully fans one is defense
the audience can't socially engineer if
you look at the box
absolutely at the very least if it's one
of the other you know what you know what
I wanna know
we want to peg down to blame see sorry
wants to take away to have dignity of
the whole situation right thank you sir
and he definitely want to put their
finger on the forehead of the the wrong
party this is very explosive I saw a lot
of a lot of people so I gotta give I
gotta change it I gotta do a little
shout out you know for our brothers and
I'd like to pie at the gravesite there
was a lot of Twitter accounts gaming
brothers who laid their lives down for
us to have this discussion you know so
rest of peace shout out to war it was a
war going on recipes Twitter share and I
want to a tip of an LOI boosting exhale
lower kids move Lord Richard of UTech
Lord BG Louis LT because just to me a
questioning of this this whole thing
with a Jeff Reed Lee says Lord PG says
if that's [ __ ] win game of the year
best direction it's gonna ruin game I
just like I said I send our condolences
to their Twitter accounts cuz these guys
got bombed forever for attacking that
there may be some ethical digs and you
know I just even if it's just one out at
one minute after day they at least
allowed us to question and that's my
thing my thing is look I haven't played
def stranded I am NOT gonna sit here and
fraud and say the thing game
not deserve given here I laid it right I
just knew that based on looking I'm
going to say with the with the core
gameplay mechanics it wasn't for me now
I got people that I trust on both sides
of this thing that played it and they
say cog this thing ain't it you know I'm
saying like this is boring I am not
having fun
then I'm having people shout to hold
more who finished it they saying
masterpiece you know I'm saying you get
to a little bit but the storytelling the
connective aspect of the game you don't
say like people or it's a very
polarizing game we have to say that
right so the whole thing comes down to
okay I feel that because like I said
like I've played it I'm not gonna
comment on it but at the same time as
far as the game award it's not an ethics
with the game awards my whole thing is I
love the game was I don't want it to go
away it's like our Oscars right we only
got nothing like this it isn't right
always all I'm saying is I don't like
the verbage and the rhetoric is saying
because he said that he doesn't vote
that is the end of discussion that there
is no corruption there is no any no
conflict of interest right that that's
my issue like we are a no collusion to
question it like soft doesn't just
because he doesn't have any influence in
terms of voting doesn't mean he has no
influence whatsoever that's my point
all broken missing I am saying
definitively the man is engineering
awards for this show objects don't look
good when one you are the founder
producer and host writes his man
right he got his man shine then you're
in the gate I don't wait okay that's
number one number two like like saw
mentioned for Mitsu you know I'm saying
this revered outlet for reviewing games
that rarely give a game of perfect score
perfect score this guy not only was in
there standing this guy was also in
metal spew some curve if I'm correct
perfect score Vanessa that people like
that are the ones voting damn for the
holding right so again all I'm saying we
gotta - all I'm saying is they are not
let's say they are innocent they are not
giving the game it's not fair to Kojima
right close because at the other day now
people are going to question like yo
this doesn't feel right this doesn't
seem right and the only thing I'll say
to Psalm point which is very important
which is again we know he doesn't he
claims he doesn't fold these not on the
board I get that but everybody claims
like one of those things he goes in the
PO he sits right before he's like how
you vote for kojima is that when you are
that close and we all agree kijima was
wrong right we all agree the way it was
handled was terrible
yeah what's call it Keighley stop the
show was very emotional you know this is
his friend you just make it your point
against him right now I'm invested right
he stopped he stopped the show to
acknowledge and have a special song
played for him after keeper suddenly
went up to get the award
so the whole point of the matter is we
cannot deny because he stopped his own
show for this right that he has
influence that's all I'm trying to say
yes listen I think the whole thing
stinks from high heaven but not to say
it's just him it's all
over the board looks bad baby did you
guys get the note did you guys get Brett
where he said he asked me yeah we got so
we have dizzy dizzy with the $5 super
chat but the biggest question should be
Jedi fallen order launch are released
they were not nominated push the next
year against the Last of Us - in
cyberpunk yeah you know what he they
definitely know what's funny is Jedi
could have won Game of the Year this
year yeah it was that good but it's
about beating them games next year you
had a shot shout out get the next one
brap with the $2 super chat I'm playing
- frantic it's top 5 game of the year
get the next one somebody so we got $2
super captain stitch it says fraud alert
fraud alert got a $2 super trap from
shrink Kingdom check Joffre brett Sony
and Nintendo and Microsoft helped
financially back the award shows -
regarding fit it's a they only have one
vote to the other 79 outlets perfect
call well you know what you know what
Brett there's countless people that are
saying this game in a negative light
it's still Game Awards infamous ooh the
fermenting problem is the tens the 40
out of 40 not the only one that did that
also we got another cat daddy facet
kijima is Jeff you know we got that part
out well I don't we got it so obviously
we have a lot you know to say about this
thing it's very controversy so my whole
thing is again we are allowed to
question that that's just what I want to
get across you know I'm saying and then
the only thing is about you know the
whole process like you know as far as we
all know you know relationships and just
being a transfer
and the fact they remembered it for
Mitsu guy they had to find out like that
wasn't immediately transparent that
these guys are in the game you know I
said we know Conan O'Brien's in the game
that's another story I get that you know
saying but at the end of the day
transparency they need to do that and
then as far as the whole voting thing
you know I'm saying and I really want to
make get this point out and I want to
shout out Kotaku cuz they she had a X I
believe Heather Alexandria um did she'd
be a great point this is what she said
an article she saying the game was like
many other big awards show is a quagmire
of potential conflicts of interests it
is as much a celebration of the year as
games it is an opportunity to bring in
viewers to show hot new trailers and
revealing big new games the show is
peppered with commercials and exclusive
reveals from the same companies whose
games are nominated for awards and whose
members are on the game awards boards
and they said of course one look at the
Hollywood reveals a similar situation
anyone who's participating the Oscars
and Emmys might tell you but there's a
key difference here and this is Saul's
point the Oscars and Emmys aren't
associated with a single man the Game
Awards has existed since 2014 and has
been produced hosted and promoted by
Geoff Keighley
his public relationship with Kojima
ultimately affects how people might read
into death strandings nominations and
any potential eventual wins that is the
point here again Europe no one is saying
definitively corruption one ethic
absolute power corrupts absolutely one
of the biggest things I wanted to point
out that I heard sauce say earlier is
why do we only get 10% of the equation
here like why that makes no sense to me
that's like you're giving 90% to the
people who gave this gamer to that
attended stuff like no I get it though I
mean listen I read the review the route
the rules as to why you know they have
the timber saying and a lot of it they
say it's socially but I do agree I do
wish the fans had more of an issue be
like 7030 you should not be nice yeah
yeah that feels like it's Loki trying to
try it trying to fix the race like that
really does you give the people that
actually has like you know a voice you
give them 10% but you can
people that that we just pointed out you
know the finishes like they're the ones
that giving this game at I ten out of
ten right they're giving this game
almost perfect scores and doing nothing
but talking negative about it in the
review you're giving them ninety I mean
it's interesting like I said hopefully
you know this could be a teaching point
for him moving forward that he made
Keighley please how'd that go idea that
he baby to recuse himself a little bit
more you know say shout out to rapper
two eyes we need you have to produce the
blue Tripp I'm not saying that you know
Jeff's going intentionally and you know
telling people holding the gun to they
had you vote for Jeff for your you vote
for Keely are you done yeah I'm saying
that the whole system needs to be
reworked I feel like he's not doing it
I'm saying it just I feel like Star Wars
it coming out on the 15th that being so
highly rated they should have like look
we got to make an exception we have to
wait a couple day so we could put that
in there cuz we know our fans want it no
I feel like there's multiple things like
like the fact that straining
action-adventure I don't think anyone is
going to be happy with award shows all
right this is the worst one I've seen in
a long list like trailers um so two new
games I like to focus on new stuff
coming out and I don't care about what
somebody else goes for what today I'm
gonna vote for whatever I like oh my god
I got a I'm gonna read this I'll okay I
looky what this training this week
besides the new game announced with the
awards are boring let's try you the best
I will say this this is probably the
most polarizing game I've ever come
across it III want to go over the power
of real quick just say your quick thing
yeah if that's [ __ ] ones game of the
year what do you think the reactions
gonna burn
that's my it's gonna be a mess it's
gonna be hot out here these streets but
look we gotta move on attic I mean King
when I just braised on your topic as far
as Amazon and then we got here oh listen
I told you guys I'm Sean's coming that's
it
Amazon's coming they're in a building
yeah real quick or Project X cloud
supposed exclusive games now solve has
been debunked they've made a statement
and they said that they are on the actor
correct I believe mm-hmm Steve Iver they
said basically they contact the survivor
to clarify their position on the EXO 19
they said we are investigating a variety
of new capabilities made possible by the
cloud a statement from a Microsoft
spokesperson however we remain committed
to an approach with game streaming that
is a cut that is complementary to
counsel and have no plans for cloud
exclusive content at this time and I
think when they say cloud exclusive
content as at per se as a game
specifically made for the cloud but I do
think they will sort of go along that
route same thing that stadia said they
were gonna do like on stadia you can
have a game with like a thousand people
in it I think I think right right
something like that's an addition to a
regular regular Xbox game that they can
do that with a multiplayer or something
like that that's their business model
but um maybe if that allows us to get
the world of warcraft with the 15-man
rage and all that other scale it the
power to crawl out shine through because
now we're seeing all these plans that
they put into place and before they was
talking prematurely I was talking out of
turn they were talking from a position
of weakness they wasn't talking from a
position of strength 50 loads of powers
people um what you have to understand
you never talk out of turn you don't
talking to you ready you never let
someone force your hand and this is what
I'm talking about when I see things
happening but um yeah I believe he just
talked out of turn but those love were
later I actually agree with that too and
I just think obviously I think King you
were on to something we know you know a
lot of these services and stuff like
that is in preparation we call them
affectionately lost even the white
walkers of Google and Amazon you know
the streaming wars we feel that you know
guys are combining forces with a
Microsoft Azure cloud you see something
on board so we doing a little game of
Thrones references with this whole
streaming Wars thing Amazon I think is a
serious
I do think I mean I working on to you I
mean AWS is very widespread you know as
far as um you know we already know about
Amazon Prime and the infrastructure on
the storefront you know obviously King
you've been playing fire tablet stuffing
game for a while we have to see how
serious they commit you know I'm saying
to that but I do think that they are
something to watch out for and let's be
honest you know like Kings say when it's
all 48 laws of power thing like one
thing as you let sometimes you let
people go first and you know experiment
and then you kind of come behind and
correct it and refine so I see lost even
shaking his head so wanna give them a
minute on this topic real quick cuz our
last thing what do you feel about Amazon
in the streaming business as a contender
I mean I think from up from a company
perspective and infrastructure
perspective I don't think anyone is
better set up to succeed mmm at clout
anything than Amazon right they longer
they definitely have all the
infrastructure they know how to do it
mm-hmm they unfortunately don't know
much about gaming they kind of have like
that they have that game engine they
bought they have a game studio they
started up I don't know how successful
they've been so whether they know how to
how to navigate from up from a marketing
and kind of acting perspective than the
waters of gaming I think will remain to
be seen but yeah AWS as you say you know
it's very strong they have the
technology do it so it's definitely
possible in that perspective but you
know Microsoft for the most part is
caught up with Azure yeah you know a DBS
doesn't start but I think Microsoft
caught up in Microsoft you know you know
definitely Xbox is first and foremost
about gaming and so that no doubt yeah
my biggest concern with these larger
corporations that you know they seem to
be hollow and soulless right and they
fill up the coffee's with those people
that do have those souls and stuff like
that because let's say this is what I'm
saying god forbid I love you in-game
pass but let's take that up a bit Amazon
comes and knocks on your door and give
you that offer that you can't gain
contractually sir you know no I'm
talking about the right now he's about
on future IPs and stuff all these
individuals
the excellence in your game because your
game is excellent and they see the
excellence in your game and they
recognize that I mean what's to stop
these dudes from coming to you knocking
on door and dropping that bag down and
starting to buy up a whole conglomerate
of independent developers that are
independent at the moment right now and
you know forming their own banner so but
like you said their only fear is that
the lack of direction the lack of focus
and then you don't understand where
they're going with it where as these
bigger entities as far as Microsoft in
the gaming space Microsoft Sony and
Nintendo they have a focus they have
been here they have been able to deliver
product and they can give you a better
clear view going forward if they don't
invest in you and these dudes invest in
you that's the biggest issue that you
know we fear at the moment that's what I
think I think it's a good point actually
and I think I don't know if you guys
seen that movie thank you for smoking
but you know there's that one scene
where you know the the the former marble
man is trying to sue you know the
tobacco companies and then Aaron
Eckhart's character comes in with a big
gigantic suitcase of money and dump it
on the ground he's like well if you
don't want this let's light it on fire
think it's I think it's easy for me to
say well you know I would definitely
stick with a burpee because I'm one
whatever but I think it's a totally
different thing to be faced with that
situation and I'm only backing the truck
up that's what we call it yeah right I
mean it though don't you guys don't you
guys remember the podcast where we
talked about Loki take your bride what
it is but I also see the like you know
the predicament that everybody is
looking at when it comes to these
streaming wars and what's at stake to be
honest with you maybe these guys don't
understand that the younger generation
but we've been here long enough to
understand the comings and goings of
certain companies yes and you you've
actually been behind the desk of being
the head of companies and stuff like
that and you yourself are the head of
your company now so you have to navigate
going forward so in these uncertain
times we want to see certain things
happen we want to see certain companies
thrive but these
bigger entities as far as Google Amazon
Netflix and stuff like that that have
the streaming capabilities to get this
stuff to your house they can take over
and where do we stand then you know yeah
absolutely that's my you know hopefully
at the end of the day that the consumer
still has enough power you know through
their through their decisions of you
know which which subscription service
they support or don't support you know
to help influence things but yeah I
think I think it's always a tough
balance between you know the corporate
corporatization and the kind of hyper
you know materialization of things
personal desire and need to have fresh
new thinking as well as well as you know
fresh things to enjoy you know from all
aspects of life right call whatever and
so I think that balance has to be
maintained I think that sometimes that
balance gets out of whack and I think
you know right now it's you hear people
talk about the inequality gap a lot mmm
that's not a good thing right I think
that you effectively are living in a
monarchy right and you know it's just
done in a different way and I think
that's that's not a good thing you the
free market works when there's
competition it doesn't work when they're
your brother I also learn to run so yeah
I think all the different streaming
services are interesting I think it's
gonna be really I wonder if we'll get
back to is you know like when we were
kids and 140 is there was like you know
a handful of TV stations right yeah this
explosion of TV stations yeah the cable
companies do right they consolidate
these kids TV stations into different
packages and you know you kind of feels
like a but a couple of TV stations again
because it really you know we watch like
through these pieces are being brought
into a package and you're gonna get move
back to the movie back to whatever
mm-hmm I wonder if that will just happen
again with these streaming services like
a menu they'll all get consolidated
under certain banners and then you'll
buy the I'm interested in action movies
versus dramas or whatever and you'll
kind of it'll come full circle again I
don't I don't know but it does
definitely seem like things travel in
waves you know and it's great when
you're at the start of a wave because
it's all fresh New Orleans you kind of
know what everyone's kind of boxed it
out and figured how
squeeze all the juice out of it so it'll
be very interesting in the brokers very
well said sir we'll see what happens
I'll say every twitch integration all
that good stuff but we are going to wrap
up the show last thing we do is our poll
question so we got the new ILP poll with
the recent controversy regarding Jeff
Keeley's non-involvement regarding the
game Awards nomination process do you
feel there are still ethical concerns in
regards to - strandings nine nominations
the choices are a No
Jeff doesn't vote on nominations and
this is only an issue for fanboy agendas
that's perhaps one be yes Geoff Keighley
is founder host producer with influencer
impropriety see I don't care y'all just
bad could show two Jedi a mix full
daughter at gears five spot that is the
Graduate those are choices please Rock
to vote when he goes up to bar on ILP
Twitter Lord Steven Danton of to time
studios in the building and absolute
pleasure to happen real he actually did
the marathon state with the Lords
through Wow Wow don't expect us that was
a super treat first of all thank you for
coming into the Renwick and the fine
people find you and what do you have
going on sir well you know I'm best
place crab me is on Twitter just a 2-ton
studios you know I love and it's also
steam discussions probably doing the
other discussion place I'm at I love
chatting about games and game theory and
game design so if anyone wants to ping
down there I'm happy to dive into things
and then trip over what I'm doing
working really hard taking a little bit
of a break for Christmas going back to
Toronto area I'm actually looking
forward to some snow and you know
because I'm now in California and the
weather's beautiful you gotta get that
on time for you exactly mr. dog but I
really might want to say thanks again
guys it was really a blast chat with you
guys thanks for the support the love it
meets a ton to Sarah and I and I think
at the end of the that's why we make
these games is for guys like you that
are passionate about this stuff and I
think you're doing a great job with the
podcast in general it's it's really
interesting stuff and
I'm so married brother really means a
lot you have no idea like a sec continue
on your journey we will be tracking this
thing following you guys all the way to
release that'll be cool hopefully we get
you back in the room you know what's
once you actually get that street date
and you ain't getting past I'll be great
absolutely
addict pleasure to get you back in the
round we're gonna find people find you
what you got going on sir get me back in
the room miss les you up back soon as we
had zillion talking in the console
classic cops left every time you talk
about age oh I'm gonna call them what's
the perfect war I'm gonna call the royal
age stuff man 1 none do with that rule
they said yeah and you need to know your
history you gotta know where it came
from
damn it you got a chance to play zillion
you understand what he's talking about
billion I would get my blanket
generation gotta educate you can find me
on Twitter at Lord IOP or no that that's
that's the wrong one that's that Lord
addict IOP okay I'm still a little tired
you have to excuse me struggle today
though you can find me on youtube at
gaming addict I will be releasing my
Star Wars review Monday look out for the
yeah beat it and you can you know I want
it I want to thank Stephen for coming on
here definitely gonna review your game
it looks like my kind of game and I want
to thank everyone for coming in the chat
you know even brat you know we might
joke around but I got my love for Brett
and I'm gonna go eat breakfast I'll talk
to you guys
Lord sovereign in the round waked upon
people funds which you got going on sir
first out first off like big shout out
to Stephen and Sarah this day I'm
absolutely so excited for the game
everything about the game is for me from
from the look of it which is evocative
of like of another world and like you
know below and inside and things like
that from the combat that in its
simplicity kind of reminds me of you
know Street Fighter back in the day how
we used to you know and even Tekken like
to you know the first iterations the
Tekken where it it mat distance mattered
and and and into stings like that that
just it's simple but at the same time
very deep and then obviously the
environmental storytelling with you know
with the with the music and the ambience
everything about this game screams me
I'm so excited I'm so glad that you guys
are in a position now where you you can
worry about the art not worry about the
money so Mike's finishing the art I'm so
excited for you guys I'm so excited for
this game so thank you for coming
through shout out the game pass helping
with multi-platform conversion to talk
okay Lord Steven I would like to thank
you and your wife for sharing a story
today it's it's it was truly beautiful
and very powerful and it also tells
people that you and your partner can
make it through things so I trust me it
did there was a very great story and I
think because you're living it but also
kognito with his dog determination I'm
telling you I had to hear so much about
this game he's like you know I'm telling
you it has levels when you're fighting
it's like a fighting game but it's like
Oh flashback and he was so on to it and
then when it popped up on the screen and
then when he reconnected with you guys
also I'm privy to the background
you're supposed to be honorable
he's like you're no more we were gonna
be on they're gonna be on and this day
was so anticipated yes I was so out of
it today like my throat I'm out of it
button after I watch the vignette there
was no way in hell that I was gonna miss
this show today because you deserve that
level of respect because all the hard
work even in the vignette I'm like my
god I gotta play this game so when I saw
us come in a game pass it allowed me to
understand that okay we privily be
certain things but there's other people
that are going to get a chance to touch
your game and you're going to spread all
over and you will be remember you will
be immortalized because I can see your
heart in that game cells trust I hope
that you are gonna open up a whole new
genre I hope that genre is talked about
the Steven John and the Steven savage
onra you understand and going forward
that stuff is definitely recognized
because I do appreciate your time here
guys I'm anybody that joined today god
bless thank you so much we do appreciate
everybody that joins the room part of
the patreon part of the podcast that you
guys sitting through us too for 3-4
hours and our retainer ship is so
beautiful and you guys in the chat are
so so nice to each other I mean you'll
go back and forth but it's not
disrespectful you're very clean very
nice and I do appreciate that because
what we pride ourself on his family
first and today is the epitome of family
first and that was so beautiful facts
well second you can you see the King
statues in the back go check that out
and combat talk is up you know check
that out and also watch law kognito any
Monza's as they talk about what's going
on with this um name of it again anthem
the other took a little Jedi fall order
two or less yes yes man saluted Kenya
King said it best man at the end of the
day like I said so shooted chat today
everybody was fantastic
you know I salute everyone who didn't
know about run to the end and I saw them
guys give me that information
okay no you don't salute them and
support our independent developers man
again creative thought things that
sometimes you know might not be able to
go under the the big Tripoli Ben they're
the only ones willing to take risk it
take the risk
unlike the EA's that's been making the
same Daisy we might want to show easy
fella we're huge fans anytime that
represent the thoughts of the Lord
seriously like I said just to see the
journey and to hear the story these are
the things we like to celebrate the
stories that you don't hear you know as
gamers sometimes were selfish why isn't
this game coming out we want we want
knowing this other crap and you really
hear the truth behind these things and
that that's the stuff we try to
celebrate so salute to that saluting
chefs and subscribers again the audio
will be going up by Lorde combat soo on
all your major audio platform's later
tonight we'll have to pull up tomorrow
and lastly quelle please support Lords
of gaming got neck great articles great
reviews more stuff coming in from the
team so please check us out that's
before you close out next week we're
gonna we're gonna ask Lord neither what
he feels about Gears five oh yeah you
can see the whole game everybody on that
but please everybody enjoy your Sunday
or not not everybody got anything else
Happy Thanksgiving to all and if you
don't celebrate Thanksgiving just spend
some time with your family
we don't condone with Lord he is saying
all right the iron Lords podcast besides
them we eat meat all right
we didn't miss it it's late I gotta get
to a football game later